are you dreaming about playing apex raid
of shadows in your sleep
he makes real shadows
[Applause]
on purpose what's up friends and chris
welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste podcast i'm
the boy and i'm with the boys and chris
and uh what is going on with your head
well i won worse drip right laziest lazy
whatever it is when i won that i thought
something with coffee right like because
i used an espresso
machine i thought laziest dripped coffee
so i was like oh that's that's bad but
it's not too bad then i discovered it
was about clothes
and you know i'm i'm like the king of
fashions and i thought
i wanted to see me so you want lazy's
dripping you somehow came with even
worse drinks yeah
so why that's my game why the heck yeah
that's what i wanted this is this is the
the standard of drip looks like you just
walked out from the 90s
what does this hat say it says uh
jumping
jumping pounding the rock what does that
mean things i stand for
but i want to win best drip over it's
called next year
and this is the first step to making
that happen people probably clicked on
this video on the thumbnail of like this
chris and they're probably like what
happened to chris it's a new chris from
a new year but where are we what is this
place oh yeah yeah so you're the first
guest for the new studio how how do you
find it you guys used to record in a
broom cupboard
a well-decorated broom cupboard but it'd
bring cupboard nonetheless it was kind
of it was nice but this is like
what can only be described as a bonds
villains layer
i got to the building outside it's all
like tinted windows security team
to get past to get here
he was equally confused we sort of made
a team effort like he got me through the
first door
security door and then i got him through
this door
sort of a team tag team effort to get in
this ridiculous building
it is massive we could like have a game
of cricket in there
first british thing you never say that
but it is cool it's quite cool
yeah really at my depths now well yeah
we got chris back for the third time
he wanted to assert dominance as soon as
he we he found out
that we got a new studio so so chris is
like the first guest we've ever had
it's literally the show the second
episode on the new
in the new studio right yeah yeah the
second episode but chris
was not only our first guest ever but he
was the first guest of this year and now
he's the first guest on the new studio
just just knocking out all the first and
i won the the best guest and the best
drip for the worst laziest yeah
congratulations about that yeah
we do we do have something for you
that's the reason i'm here yeah
he seemed to be obviously i've been
coming to look enviously at your massive
studio space
like because i've recorded in a wardrobe
library japan's like a wardrobe and like
i come here to get an award a physical
tangible monetary
award monetary terrorist
issues something that is worth it let's
go on
ashley ashley's gone awards
this was what we had to give you i know
before you open it do you want to do you
want to give a speech or something like
that
a little acceptance yeah come on yeah
everyone that voted me for the best
guess thank you you are my favorite
everyone that
voted where strip i hate you
you're wrong and i'm going to prove you
wrong in the next year but
this is this is a guess this is an award
that uh all three of us were like
you know why not it's an award
it looks like a bomb in there
about a war i i was like guys i know
exactly what i need to get chris
is actually good yeah yeah i love it i
think it's the best
it's brilliant
japanese in japan they're kind of a very
intricate armor
[Music]
oh hold it to the camera first hold to
the camera first so it's some sort of
image
is it is it the right way is it somehow
he got it the right way first time
everyone is laughing everyone behind the
camera and ready three
two one
[Laughter]
you will forever have that immortalized
now who drew there
i'm coming for you who did this
i'm gonna use the full force of the
abroad in japan media empire to find the
person that drew this and bring them to
justice
what is it this is like a manga
yeah it's a website so this is a webtoon
that one of our fans is making yeah
it's about trash he's characterized all
of us and i gotta say i mean like
so the reason why i look like a [ __ ]
balloon what is that
i saw this on twitter chris you're in
the the trash taste
i'm in a manga and i clicked through and
it was this
and i was like which one am i my oh
[Laughter]
i remember that i remember the message
you gave me too because he sent me a
screenshot of this
and after it just said you [ __ ] what
i mean like it does look like me if we
if we remove the lower half
myself shockingly i did ask when we got
this frame
like can we get a kim jong-un sized
brilliant yeah like massive one that you
can like put on the wall and we
pray to everyone taking out the bullet
train back to center
this character it's not even killed like
chris or abroad it's just called
big mouth
big man yeah i think i think in the
webtoon we all have like special powers
that
are kind of synonymous to our
personalities
i really hope this character has
redemption on it
where he gets thin he saves the world he
gets the girl
that's just an atrocity but it does look
cool
this better be on the set yeah i'll
think about it
thank you it's the thought that counts a
lot of
yeah is it i thought i'd be like a gold
bar or something
why would we give you a gold billiard
this is trash taste yeah i think i could
sell off when my channel goes down the
toilet
i've got the trash taste prize i can
sell that off that's like worth nothing
but it is good
it's good i think how dare you thank you
very much we put a lot of
we put a lot of love and effort into
this absolutely for you this can listen
live on the table for this episode
for this episode fantastic is this
is there more like anger of this coming
out i don't think
i gave up yeah like two or three months
ago i think the guy is making a new
chapter every week or two
something like that yeah don't give him
an idea it takes time to draw things
chris
especially
that's like 70 percent of the image it's
just me
it's great you're like the center of
attention right exactly you're right in
the middle you're pushing away your
competition redemption arc and i'll be
very happy
that's that's you know netflix next one
just has to be
like this but with this hat on him
bad mouth yeah is that something you
normally wear chris or
is it something you just wear i've never
seen you wear a hat i've got a
collection of 100 yen hats this was 100
yen
right in japan you get a lot of like
hats that just come down to the end
shut up we've got some like really
obscure ingredients this is actually
like a basketball
saying right you know putting the ball
through the hoop
probably maybe only only one of my
friends knew that and he's like a top
basketball guy but he's like
it sounds like you want to have sex with
dwight johnson it doesn't matter it does
a bit but like counting the rocks
it's just so bizarre know so i have a
collection of these sort of tacky hats
at my apartment
now i'm actually wearing them and you
really feel like you you have a
collection of tacky hats and you're like
how dare you give me lazy straight
let me wear this tacky hat yeah let me
wear this does give a
like very much bad energy yeah i'm
pretty sure my dad has worn the same hat
before
i feel about that i'll take it i like
the hat
let's get best drip what is it sounds
like
like i didn't know what it meant
initially but i don't know it's a word
where
you hear it once and you hear the word
drip and for some reason for me it just
made sense right like
like busting boston doesn't make sense
right
damn that [ __ ] is blasting yeah what is
this
i feel really old now
i'm out like when something's just great
yeah so when something's really good you
got it damn that's possible i still got
uncomfortable when people use the word
sick
oh it's sick because i just i've got are
you used to the words
insulted all of australia i've got quite
a visual sort of
imagery when people when i hear a word i
picture it every time that's sick i
picked someone literally being sick
that's not sick that's horrible
i i know i'm older than you hold on
yeah yeah same as me because youthful
you look like you're in your 20s i look
like i'm in like 47 or something
with the hat especially with the hat
this is like my bridge to the youth
is a skateboard have you seen that
steven images
still part of my plan get the
demographic figure looks like he's
trying to sneak into a high school yeah
right
hello fellow kids oh my god
so what's the plan for today usually
when i come here
we don't do that here we just chat [ __ ]
like usual right excellent we've been up
to chris
yeah what have you been offering why are
you in tokyo again what have i been
doing i've filmed a building
and that's about it yeah single building
well i came down here to win my award
and uh
starting to worry that that was money
not well spent
i literally spent like a hundred bucks
it's like a four hour round trip
together
and that's just to be insulted on like
the world's biggest podcast
brilliant was it worth it a lot of
people would die for that experience oh
yeah you guys did our
journey across japan yeah yeah it's been
going we've got like a top
15 itunes hit i can't [ __ ] believe
that
i don't know how i spend so much of my
time like just off camera you know
making my own music and putting my heart
soul into it and yeah the most
successful piece of music i've ever
written
i wrote in seven hours in a car oh
there's often a cruel
you know i'll take the award it's all
right yeah so like for those who aren't
in the know what's the story behind that
we had a challenge we had to do like a
rap song so on journey across japan this
travel series we get a challenge every
day and the challenge was
produce a rap song in a day and uh we
found ourselves a volcano
and that became we had to wrap about our
day right yeah and we were on the top of
japan's biggest volcano mount assay
and that became it and natsuki said
something like what too much volcano
yeah it is isn't it that's the wrath
yeah say that over and over again say
that
i very cleverly didn't put myself in the
wrap before the video
so that's good that took the uh
took the credit but yeah yeah it turned
out really well yeah and then just shout
i put it on itunes right it costs like
19
to put a song on itunes yeah and it
takes like a few weeks and it's very
simple
but after i did that i shouted out and
it started to go up someone sent me a
link saying are you in the top
25 alternative songs on itunes i was
like i was kind of
like for that week right so it's like oh
okay you know like it's probably because
of the the initial push on top
yeah yeah yeah yeah but then but then it
just it just kept going
it just yeah yeah once i shouted out
there were on itunes it created this
sort of self-propelling
sort of cycle people funded it more
bought it more and it went up and up
until it got to
i think number 14 on the the itunes
singles chart worldwide
these poor people who bought this it's
terrible
it is worryingly catchy it's quite
addictive yeah the song hook
with that skin they're too much focus
yeah the asr too much volcano works
it works but uh yeah so i don't know how
much it sold
i don't know either i'm still waiting
for my royalties to be honest
well yeah so i gotta split that i wasn't
gonna split with that skin jerry because
i thought it'd be like make a hundred
dollars yeah i'll use that to buy a
coffee or a new hat
yeah ten hats that's a thousand hats
the drip game but because probably
around ten thousand people bought it
that's a bit more money and it makes
sense to split that with yeah with the
anastasia i think you should pocket it
only sold a hundred copies you're
mirroring the music industry where the
the guy behind yeah
yeah unfortunately it takes about three
months for itunes to tell you how well
it's done
so one day in september i'll be like
sitting in a room depressed and then
i'll get like a little letter from
itunes but by the way
you've got platinum wow
do we have permission to play a short
clip on the podcast copyright strike
time
yeah exactly yeah it's the only like the
only song that's not copyright
yeah use it to your advantage put it
everywhere yeah let's get those sails
off now we're chilling at the peak of
the volcano it looks kind of bleak
but it's okay though what went the bros
surrounded by the soul for clouds so
brace yourself cause it's about to get
loud
too much volcano no volcano
can't wait for you to take this episode
down and claim with the entire yeah
yes i will take all the revenue
do you use my song and you defamed me
but there you go it's that easy to get
the itunes hit ladies and gentlemen yeah
apparently
apparently if you have influence online
just beg your
underlings to go and uh buy it pretty
much pretty much
putting ascii in a song and it's
guaranteed to get on itunes
how was the uh the overall journey of uh
journey costume which was your
your is it annual youtube series at this
point i don't know i guess so
it was right i guess it's annual yeah
did you enjoy it yeah it was really good
i wasn't here for the whole time i did
enjoy it but like you know because i'm
always running around filming and
producing
so it takes a lot of stress because
you've got to think every day how's this
going to work
i nearly died on a horse yeah and in a
plane
in in those videos when you say like oh
it's one day is it actually one day
for the most part yeah for the most part
it was because it's like i feel like
there's way too much stuff like what
what's up
it's extremely hectic what time are you
waking up like six a.m
some days some days yeah oh my god and
we're filming till maybe
like 10 or 11 it's relentless it's a
really crazy week what's like the crew
behind that
so it's jerry myself natsuki and then we
had a guy called norm take a lens and my
friend ian he's producer
right and so it kind of works it's a
pretty small team um
quite small that's very small i mean we
we have we had like that kind of teams
for trash day specials and even we are
stretched to the absolute limit with
what we can do and just see i mean some
stuff you're able to do it's all
honestly like thanks to just like
chris's insane like organizational
skills like he just has everything being
like
we don't have that at next time we're
gonna go here until
here and then doing this after this and
then oh the weather's [ __ ] maybe we
should put this in front of this and me
and natsuki just kind of chilling in the
back like yeah all right
chris somehow doubt natsuki is too
concerned with the uh scheduling oh he
loved it it's his holiday yeah he
doesn't have to do anything right
yeah he's like riding [ __ ] horses
he's going on a volcano dancing he's
like
he literally had so much fun seeing a
cat he loved it yeah
it's the best threat for his heart
holiday of his lifetime really probably
i love how you didn't so in one of the
episodes you went to a
cave or something just didn't go in the
cake yeah i know
i would have gone in the cave i would
have got it bollocks take me there we'll
go in the cake
such a humiliating day day three journey
across japan we went in the smallest
tory gate
in japan yeah it's about 30 centimeters
in width and height like the red shrine
things you see
yeah this one was made of concrete and
it's on it's like concreted into the
ground
and i got stuck and i was like i'm going
to become a fixture here if i can't get
out of it because you can't just like
lift
the tires the [ __ ] thing and i was
really scared and you see like a moment
where i'm like
i'm [ __ ] like we literally had to grab
two adults like pull him out yeah
[Laughter]
and i couldn't go in because of an
insect that looked like something out of
alien like a face hugger
it's your series you've got to go in
there that's what i told him on the day
and he was like you don't suffer for
your content right that's that's exactly
what people are stuck in that shrine
you can go in a cave and then there was
the horse riding
i did a i ride a horse the first time
joey got like the prize winning horse
natsuki's horse was about to die
and i i got like the six-year-old horse
it was brand new they hadn't trained and
they didn't tell me
and i was the only one that hadn't
ridden a [ __ ] horse and i got on it
and it looked it turned around and
looked at me in the eye
and it like turned all the way i was
like i'm [ __ ] i knew that i was
terrified yeah yeah didn't enjoy it you
could feel the energy i turned around
and looked at me like
i was i was saying to chris i was like
you could tell that chris did not enjoy
it because in the video
it's like now we're riding horses and
like literally one minute later it's
like and now we're done
it's like i'm not including any of this
in the video and that that wasn't even
like
caught up for entertainment purposes it
was literally that quick was it really
yeah he was he was probably on the horse
for max like three minutes
yeah it was wait how long did you ride
for it was ten minutes he wrote
about an hour
and i was like i need to get off this
and like the guy's coming over and he's
like what do you want to do
get me off this [ __ ] horse throw my
camera off i sort of dived off it
i was this far from its foot and i
thought it just kicks me in the face
it's game over there i'll be honest
and i thought it might because it was
like going all like this yeah rocking
horse and like the guy got on it and he
could control it either for a bit just
whisper to it
oh the [ __ ] out no you got a sir
dominance
and then i just did the drone shots
i didn't know i was allergic to horses
until i got off and i was in the car and
i was like oh
my my every orifice in my body is
leaking right now
i'm like this is this is not good and
then i realized i'll probably do the
whole
[ __ ] hope your covers on those chairs
chris
oh god yeah well that was that was
pretty dicey the only thing scary was we
did uh
we threw in a little cessna over that
was easily scary it looked scary
that was easily the scariest thing i've
ever done yet it was fun looked all
right [ __ ] it it was scary that was very
scary over an active volcano that was
smoking right and at one point
again i don't like flying i had a really
turbulent flight once when i was about
20. at least before that i love flying i
love planes and then after that
there was like a moment i thought we
were all going to die because everyone's
screaming the plane was going all over
the place i'd like a glass of wine and i
was like
ah well and then just whatever i know
that's the main thing like the food and
the water yeah the food
starts flying it's time to worry yeah
and uh i thought i'm gonna die now
and then i didn't i was oh good but then
every time there's like turbulence on
the plane my body
has a sort of fight or flight response
right it's called ptsd yeah pretty much
how i feel when i watch a sea dog va
video
yeah so i get i get nervous flying in
planes and uh
so you choose she chose to fly on the
[ __ ] washing machine well he
pressured me into it he's like um
you got to do it also you're [ __ ]
talking about some shitty app that tells
you if you're going to die
yeah yeah like why would we worry on
earth would you want to know if your
plane is going down that's exactly what
i said
because every time you tell someone
you've got a fear of flying they're like
i don't never crash
but i'm like yeah they do look one in a
million times
and that's still one more than i want
it's like you fly over like russian
airspace and get shot down for some
reason reason i
because if it was it'd be like you have
a one in four chance
so yeah every time you get a taxi it's
way more likely you're
oh that's what i told them before we got
on i was like you're more much more
likely to die
you're driving to the airport it's more
chance you've done it but i think it
just
it feels like your life is kind of in
your control because
yeah kind of when you're on a plane
you're you're if you're [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] and there's nothing you can do
about it
exactly right and we only had one pilot
and he was kind of old and i thought
we're flying over this cellphone
like a taxi driver story in a plane well
like exactly all right we're flowing
through the sulphuric ash cloud that
came into the plane
yeah because the guy was like open the
window i don't think i will
oh yeah the window seat we opened that
actually
right now and i i don't know why i got
that seat in hindsight should not have
been me
and i'd sort of show you how to open the
window and close it and i couldn't like
shut it but like
yeah it got to the volcano i had to open
it and all this ash and just
meet it there's a methane like sulfuric
acid the pilot has like a stroke
who's gonna fly the plane or something
like that
you know the plane's going you can see
in the video the plane's going up and
down joey's terrified yeah
he was like oh yeah it's gonna be
[ __ ] fun and then we get in it and
it's like a [ __ ]
thrown around like a dog toy and he's
like bouncing around
he's terrified in the second half i
actually quite enjoyed it because i was
the filmmaker of me came out ah this is
quite fun and then he starts getting
meanwhile i'm sitting there without a
camera
so i'm feeling everything you can see
him like
all right this is actually [ __ ]
terrifying now yeah it didn't look quite
like it looked really cool but also yeah
did it like you would be shooting
yourself a little bit yeah and then i
asked the pilot before it took off like
is you know is this safe he went
maybe maybe that's not [ __ ] good
enough
i'm not brought in japan you can't tell
me 3 000 feet over an active volcano
with joey like that's a terrible way to
die
specifically jerry specifically i think
i think the only reason why the first
half for me was bearable
was just because i got to watch chris
[ __ ] his pants
right next to him like that in and of
itself was like this
entertainment right here negates all
fear that i'm feeling right now
when chris i feel like i remember what
it was but it was so sketchy and chris
kept looking at me like
oh wait no you know what it was it was
when we were [ __ ] we went skiing
you mean we got stuck up the hill i do
vaguely
the car couldn't get up the hill oh yeah
and it was so sketch
because wait wait what was the story
okay so
me and chris when i went up to visit
chris and then uh chris took me to
watsonville ski resort in yamagata yeah
really nice place and
it was great because the hotel that
chris had chosen was on the screen slope
so when you
when you like wake up you literally just
grab your stuff
yeah you put them on as you get out of
the hotel down to the entrance of the
hotel
clip them off and should be like all
right boys okay the onsen
acid onsen which we'll talk about yeah
but when we came to this place
it's up a massive steep hill like this
really steep probably
ridiculous and i think chris had rented
a two-wheel drive
i thought it was a four-wheel drive it
was a two-wheel drive and there was no
was there
tires on it definitely more snow tires
and it was an icy hill
yeah we just stopped going up this and
then suddenly you're like
where he wants you to look more
terrified yeah he's terrified and he's
like look terrified look more terrible
he was doing that
like as we were going up the entire time
just gripping my knee with like the
[ __ ] strength of a gorilla don't edit
that out yeah i think so
for that there's nothing to hold on to
because you feel like you're bouncing
around in the air yeah you've got to
hold on to something
i'm just holding on to my knee
he's got my knee in a vice group and i'm
like i can't [ __ ] move right now
chris
like oh eventually got saved by
i had to get out of the thing climb up
this hill go to the hotel and be like
help then i had like tell him what was
going on and this guy like you know that
meme where the kid is on like the gear
stick he like slaps it around
into gear like really fast this old man
jumps in this
massive truck slams the gear down really
fast and
starts going and then he spun the car
around and then drove down the hill yeah
yeah and then he comes down
gets it gets like get out of your car
chris gets in the car spins it around
and then brings it back up this man was
insane what a chat
he was such a like chad it was just like
a drifting king it sounds like something
out of initial deal yeah
it was like the drift king who like
retired in the mountains yeah
these corners were tiny and he was
driving like a 10-seater van
like up these things super fast he was
crazy
that's how i feel about you know those
like massive bus drivers who like drive
the mountain roads yeah
and then he was like four-wheel drive
addy muscat or something
he did say that like 4wd addie musk and
i was like
what no no no no we're not smart
we're stupid so every time i've ever
gone anywhere snowy now i'm like 4wd
snow ties please yeah yeah yeah
because i thought like we're going to
[ __ ] die we're going to keep going
down this hill i mean yeah that's how
like cars like toppled
or and we were on a corner so they're
easily a car
it was pretty sketch that whole trip was
it was just hilarious look at chris just
putting his friends into precarious
situations
get ready for you guys yeah i guess what
what are you gonna do for me chris
here we go
[Laughter]
japanese guillotine experience you're
going first right
seppuku experience
this video is sponsored by apari aparra
is releasing their spring summer
collection which we'll be releasing
today at 8 pm what is this drip you're
wearing chris
chris chris is dripping down laziest
drip no get out of here chris
get out of here is that an aparri
message i am now the most ripped
i look fantastic and i feel great i am
wearing the ox t-shirt which is pigment
dyed and vintage washed and oh
this feels so [ __ ] good right now
guys yeah i'm wearing the ox sweater and
i don't know if you boys can see this
but this is all woven in detail this is
incredibly extra but it's so thick and
well made
i probably can't wear it much now in
japan but yeah in the winter it's going
to be amazing
and i'm wearing the button-downs which
are really breathable this is like the
perfect shirt to wear
this time of year right now in japan
it's very breathable very light
very nice for the summer apart is an
artist owned apparel brand focused on
delivering clothes with fun color
concepts and high quality fabric and the
brand features original art inspired by
retro motifs and
japanese animation gentlemen the drip is
dropping at 8 p.m tonight and they will
sell out fast so what are you doing
click the links in the description down
below to get your own aparri merch
before it sells out don't miss out on
their new collection or restocks by
following their instagram and mailing
list that's at a party yard for
instagram or
aparri.com don't be the laziest trip
we're a party
look like me back to the episode i've
we've done a video with each of you now
in like a hot tub
like a bath so i actually got now yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah that video got so many
complaints because of the whole
breakfast ordeal
i got so much [ __ ] for that really yeah
i got so many comments people what did
you say
so uh there was um we stayed i found
this thing on booking.com that was like
a five-star
um hotel but it was just a town house in
kyoto
and uh yeah it was all right it was
would you say it's five stars lovely
connor's really the dichotomy of man
right it's not easy to impress with
anything the living room
there's not a tesco mildew in here
this is five stars right and you come in
this living room and there's a tv
that's like 12 inches yeah on a shelf
and there's nothing in this living room
it's literally nothing the record plan
there was a record player which is
pretty cool oh nice
and had like a bunch of vinyl you have
to bring your own final player no they
had their
they had vinyls and that was cool but
there was
it was just a living room with nothing
in it yeah absolutely like no chip
one bean bag one one bean bag but it had
two bedrooms
it had two bedrooms right so chris got
the deluxe
king triple comfort bed and i had to
sleep on the the floor
yeah [ __ ] uh what's it called through
tom
as you can see that's better than that
and then i had a bath with the bath was
really nice but
there's the old [ __ ] lady staring at
her yeah so it came out the front of
this kyoto town house and i looked up
and it was like this old woman just
peering over the edge like
and i was oh my god the [ __ ] what's she
doing it was like resident evil really
yeah and she was like looking at me yeah
and then i went back in the house
there's a woman
so how much was it 500 a day i don't
know
500 bucks a day oh damn no no no no it
wasn't it wasn't everybody
like that's pretty [ __ ] expensive 300
yeah it's about 280
a day yeah and it came with a free
breakfast you didn't have a say it just
turned up well
the thing is i noticed that ryokans are
like ridiculously expensive but most
that cost
is just the breakfast that you don't
have a choice
i would say if this didn't come with the
food it'd probably be 200 bucks like the
food
it came at like 8 00 a.m it's a great
breakfast
this is where the controversy what i've
controversy we've got a few comments
like how dare you
yeah where this breakfast just gets
delivered to you hey outside and you you
open it up and it's just like 10 kind of
radish
just radish and like tofu and i'm not
being funny at 8 a.m
and i think we were hungover one day
we're just like i was like no no i'm not
eating this yeah ordered a mcdonald's
townhouse audacity yeah
terrible but what was the controversy
then well they were like how dare you
waste the food but i it was probably
was it one of the worst ones you've ever
seen it was pretty awful it wasn't
anything in there that i got excited
about put it that way yeah
it was pretty bad and then there was a
whole lot i got like my friend was like
they were like how dare you waste it i'm
like no i'm a customer i'm not wasting
it i
i don't get a say in whether it turns up
i didn't ask for it yeah yeah yeah
yeah but do you feel bad because like i
it's
that i must not be the only person doing
it no you're not but like
there's just something about saying in
japanese ryokan where like i feel bad if
i don't
eat the breakfast because someone's
specifically prepared and
like the thing is i don't want the
japanese breakfast if i had a choice
like
i wouldn't get it most of the time
because i remember the one time that we
stayed in ryokan and we had a
quite a bit of a heavy night and then
joey was [ __ ] hung over the next day
yeah i couldn't see me you and maki
waiting downstairs and i just felt so
bad because this like old lady had
obviously prepared this like [ __ ]
five course meal or something joey
[ __ ] waddles in
an hour late takes one look at the
breakfast takes one bite of the fish and
you're just like
nope i can't do it no i can't do it guys
some days
i tried i tried so hard i was like only
like two things but like
if i eat any more it's going back onto
the plate
it's really heavy as well i have that
multi-culture right like don't waste it
yeah yeah i i you know i always try my
best to eat what i can yeah
but some days i'm just like i really
just don't want breakfast and also if i
eat this i'm just gonna feel like [ __ ]
so at the end of the day i've paid for
this yeah and i don't have to eat it i'm
a big boy i could i could decide not to
eat it because right it's like
rice like a [ __ ] ton of miso soup fish
a bunch of other [ __ ] at the time i
could do the miso soup because that's
like nice
that's nice it's like nice in the
stomach so like i can eat that
yeah fish maybe fish is dependent this
is maybe yeah yeah yeah
because like i don't eat breakfast a lot
normally
yeah so like a japanese breakfast it's
like a five course meal
or something like that and this is more
than i have for lunch let alone a
[ __ ] breakfast yeah like
it's like it's like a breakfast you give
to someone who hasn't eaten in three
days you know it's like
it's it's a shitload i mean i mean you
dine like a king but at the same time a
king even
isn't that hungry when he wakes up first
thing in the morning i don't [ __ ]
know
even the kids like chill the [ __ ] out
from henry
you're [ __ ] morbidly obese that's how
you start your day yeah it's ridiculous
and
you know at the end of the day if you're
a customer i'm like you know what i'd
only do this i
don't know i don't want to oh yeah i
mean you know if you paid for it then
it's your choice right
you know i mean yeah it's not like i i
called them up and like bring the
breakfast it gets here it's [ __ ] i don't
want it yeah it's like
it's coming no matter what they're
making it regardless yeah yeah
because like with my plate most places
like breakfast is optional but with it
with a ryokan it's just part of the
package and you have no choice to not
have it
all of the times it is i can hear a lot
as well right i feel like
i could eat a lot but these things are
massive like if you're like
you know a smaller person who doesn't
eat much there's no way you could finish
it that's why i'm always like surprised
like with the amount of food that
arrives right and i'm like
how does like an 80 year old japanese
woman get up in the morning and eat
all of that i know right like hell you
just take one bite
yeah i mean it's great the first
experience because you're like man this
looks [ __ ] amazing
it's like an instagram meal you take a
picture looks amazing posted and you're
like [ __ ] i've gotta actually eat this
now
[ __ ] i didn't think about that it's just
not sass i mean coming from the uk where
we have like
a big plate of everything yeah it's like
i miss british fry-ups more than like
anything about the uk
yeah i can't even do those either
because it's like i'm just i don't wake
up in the morning and feel hungry
it's more of a lunch thing it's a brunch
brunch
yeah yeah you kind of eat it like twelve
one after you've read it oh okay then
yeah
yeah yeah have you guys ever had a good
british kind of fry up
in japan no no no still not found
anywhere that does it
i found fish and chips but like that's
like the one thing i can't find
you found good fish and chips chips are
[ __ ] fish and chips are so boring
it is the english breakfast i want a
home got one right
yeah and shibuya it's all right that's
probably the best one i've had it's
pretty good yeah
really yeah but like i'm i'm not crazy
i've never gotten
chicken fish and chips you know like
like either
you've got some of the best fish like
dishes here in japan yeah yeah
you look at that you're like you know
what [ __ ] this i feel like fish and
chips
i feel like i'm expected to eat it
because all my years here right
whenever i go oh yeah i'm from the uk oh
everyone's one of three things it's like
oh yeah david or all the spice girls
fish and chips so it was one of the few
things about british culture so i've
kind of like i should probably enjoy
anything else
what like british cuisine we have a
crisp sandwich
baked beans bread sandwich sunday roast
oh sunday right
is there is there a sunday roast place
in japan yes hobgoblin
good one big advert it is good basically
just good
goblin apparently yeah and you'll
probably bump into us there because we
go there yeah
quite a lot yeah genuinely [ __ ] but uh
yeah no british food's hard to come by
unfortunately sausage rolls
greg's i do miss greg's actually if it's
a franchise couldn't you just buy one
and bring it here
i don't think it's the first one tastes
great yeah like it's not oh what's going
on
yeah oh the trash tastes great it's also
not greg's unless it's like one pound
like it has to be cheap as [ __ ]
like if it greg's is full you can make
it a hundred yen right yeah there's no
way you could get the cost
do it oh my god greg you [ __ ] do it
i'm not doing it
why should i do it you've got a studio
the size of spain right you can you can
get a greg's digital that's how you make
your first meal bringing grapes
you could do selling sausage rolls
anything else you missed about england
that you like that you crave
boris johnson
[Laughter]
obviously and here comes all the
dislikes oh finally you can you can be
in my corner in this one
because i've had arguments with them
where there's always a slippery slope
tries
well i i have to argue with these boys
because that like tokyo architecture is
amazing i know that you
are up with me where you think like
london is just beautiful the
architecture is amazing it is
yeah objectively and these boys are like
no it's boring it's boring it's all the
same
well i mean look at this district here
look out the window you know there's no
interesting architectural buildings i
kind of like the the feel of japan it
feels like one big theme park
because everything's kind of clean the
building's made out of some sort of
weird woody
plastic material it just feels like a
thing park almost but it looks ugly
it looks great it looks great japan
japan is literally
one of the most aesthetics like
countries
in the [ __ ] world all those areas
look really cool but when you start
going like 10 minutes out of center it
all just starts to look like an
amalgamation of just
doesn't every country look like that no
no no [ __ ]
every country got a [ __ ] croydon i i
beg to differ sir
every country you go every every country
you go ten minutes out of the city
center and it all looks the same
in the uk the high is very high and the
loads are very lively yeah i'm low
jokingly before natsuki came to uk i
said where do you want to go in the uk
the most point uh croydon
how do you know what
like one of the most depressing places
possibly been to my life he's still yet
to go
yeah why does he want to go croydon no
you have to deal with i don't know how
did he learn
he must have been it must have been like
a band that you know
he heard it like from you maybe one time
no i know that sounds like a place i
don't i don't sit in
north japan talking about croydon
yeah i don't know where he got it from
but no i'd say the architecture of japan
unfortunately japan is losing a lot of
its old kind of historic buildings
harajuku station the nakagin capsule
building is going next year
um the cool sega building an arcade in
akihabara yeah they've got a very
utilitarian mindset here and connor's
choking to death
right now he's gone time to take over
his channel
but like yeah they've got a very
utilitarian mindset as long as it gets
the job done
that's the main thing and if you go to
someone like tokyo station
all the skyscrapers look the same
they're all kind of i mean yeah
that part of japan is or tokyo is quite
bland and grey
and you can go to any town across japan
it looks more or less the same you'll
have the same things there's no
it's rare to find good historic
architecture i mean i
think it's about the historic
architecture though no i think i like
that though i like the building it is it
is cool like the historical architecture
in japan is cool but i think as well
like
i think like the aesthetic that a lot of
people love about japan is like kind of
the
alleyway i mean i love that yeah the
golden guy looks awesome
[ __ ] amazing area yeah but everywhere
else is just so depressing it all just
looks like a mess
i kind of think london is like that most
of it if it's not if it's not zone one
or zone two then
what have what have we got really it
looks really good i think all the
buildings are like i don't know i
really like the look it's really nice
pretty well designed
well because you lived in morden i was
like what's there in morden
because i i lived in strength and
strathmore
just sounds like a [ __ ] like lord of
the rings area it sounds
a lot cooler than it looks like we're
going to morden
it looks pretty nice i like that nobody
enters morden i do remember
when i went back to the uk for the first
time in two and a half years i remember
looking up and going okay the uk's
architecture is pretty good the old
brick buildings and whatnot
you know in central london but uh yeah
in central london yeah
pretty nice all the customers chris
hates landings he's english
oh well sorry it smells good
yeah yeah tom jones right angles
are you see on holiday in anglesey north
wales why
went canoeing oh kayaking good
englishman come to our land
take advantage of our
yeah you showed me around sendai he's
like look it's just a big apartment
building in the middle of like
this like i took you to an 80s bar yeah
yeah i was good with it
is that the one you took me to i think
so right probably yeah
no 60s bar oh the 60s we were driving to
the ski resort right because it's like
look there's just
a big apartment building in between all
these [ __ ] normal houses
yeah it's like weird thing where like it
just looks so out of place it was like
some kind of lord of the rings apartment
building
it's true like yeah in yamagata there's
just a rice field and some plains a few
huts
and then there's like 150 foot buildings
it's like the town it's like showers
had loads of money and was friends with
like the governor of yamagata apparently
and he's like yeah i want to build a
tall building you know get people coming
he was like i could make it happen they
did it
i think it was a failure and then what's
all this building is like just in a
field it's ridiculous
the reason why you pack people so dense
like that is because they're close to
something of
value like something you know like a
station or one right that's the reason
why that works not because there's rice
fields
it's like yeah like kowloon wall city
the thing what if all the rice farmers
want to live
like close to each other farmers need
land for their tools and she can't bring
it back into his condo apartment his
[ __ ] tractor
where's she gonna put it but i feel like
that that's part of the charm of japan
right because it feels like there are no
rules and
you know you can find the most random
places or random things in the most
random places
there's no rules in the most
bureaucratic country in existence
in terms of architecture because they're
too busy with [ __ ] hanko stamps
yeah if a building should be built or
not no definitely in terms of
architecture like japan
i feel has no rules yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] japan and that's like what other
countries out there being like you know
what we need a town based around wales i
mean
even [ __ ] england doesn't do that and
yeah and yet it was still better than
wales
22 [ __ ] dollars for fish and chips
we got
you'd be surprised we talked about that
podcast before yeah
chris took me and there's a sulfur bath
in one of them
it was horrible how was that
it was like yeah i come up with the ph
was it was like one it was uh two but it
was a
it was
ph2 is like very dangerous especially
especially to bathroom
you dude you get in it and you get out
your skin is all red
and my it kind of makes your skin
tingling yeah yeah you feel it i was
saying to god
why is this a thing yes
when you go in this onsen right it we
didn't realize because i think it said
only five minutes but me and chris were
in there for like 30 minutes
and uh it was horrible we came out and
like when you when you do it your skin
you can't yeah two is one of the most
acidic phs you can do one is at the end
i know how the [ __ ]
scale works it's zero to seven gone i
understand the numeric scale
but no google the onsen google onsen ph
levels
i i can read from zero to fourteen
that's not the same thing
let me
[Laughter]
it's like it's really cool because like
the snow is falling all around you it's
outside and
you go out and you yeah you're just like
you're stinging your whole body yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's just like bathed
in acid of course it would have yeah
right
clean some of it yeah yeah ps2 is legit
yeah yeah it was told you was it two
h2 because when i was waiting for chris
when i was waiting for chris because
every single onsen has a sign outside of
it telling you all the chemical makeup
and the ph
and i saw it was like 2.1 and i was like
[ __ ] hell that's
if you've been in there like that's
illegal in most countries last few hours
yeah you would yeah yeah right
five minutes and we were in there for 30
minutes
like it could be a video like an
endurance set so you can stay in the
longest but it come out just bones
that's like the skeleton it's like a mr
beast video it was
it survived the acid bar i'll give you
ten thousand dollars it felt really good
though when you when you got out because
you just felt
as clean as you've ever been
you [ __ ] sanitize your entire skin
it's not fun it's not good
i'm pretty sure that's how people like
remove tattoos
and all these skin peels just going like
that yeah that's so horrible
i highly recommend trying i couldn't
like sleep that night [ __ ] off don't
take our word don't take it don't listen
to cause
i think i'd rather bathe in ethanol
bathing hand sanitizer i think that's
that's safer but this is more fun
i did not sleep that night could you
imagine if you like accidentally drank
the water
oh well actually you can't really i
don't think you can drink the water at
the hotel because
it's like this hotel stunk like do you
remember how bad it just smelled like
the whole
default yeah because the whole because
it's because it's all like built on
sulfur right so this is cause you're
bathing in a volcano
so you like you're saying in this room
and you cannot stop smelling
rotten eggs in farts i was like
chris this chris or just i can't [ __ ]
tell
it's just chris was like ripping a fat
one like every five minutes have you
guys ever been in a denki boot
what's like an electric i have yeah no i
haven't passed an electric current
through the walls it's like yeah yeah
i didn't know what it was it's horrible
so i walked into this bath once walked
through i was like why are my legs
tingling am i having a heart attack
and then i i saw like the kanji for
electricity and bath and i was like [ __ ]
why are you having a laugh and they yeah
they they run a low voltage current
through
you are kidding me yeah it's the same
feeling as the sulfuric water basically
it feels like acid but oh is that it's
kind of scary just actually slipped and
put the
voltage up like 10 times
things that shouldn't be mixed is like
electricity and water i'm pretty sure we
learned that when we were like
three like it's like someone dropping
like a little toaster in the [ __ ]
there's a toaster in the waters like oh
yeah
i don't know yeah i remember i went in
that once when i was very young
and again i didn't know it either what
it was so the moment i stepped in i was
like
mommy i'm dying what's happening why
can't i not stay
worse acid acid bath with electricity
thousand dollar challenge you would
stand at the longest thousand dollars
does like japan have health and safety
regulations
you can go don't think so it's too it's
safe
it's safe i'm just wondering imagine
like trying to pitch this idea in the uk
all right all right we're gonna do like
a special bath it's gonna
people can bathe in acids you can drop a
toaster but you won't die
i once went to the most like one of the
most dangerous temples in them
in south japan and you climb up a cliff
face with just like a metal chain
if you let go you just die and i didn't
realize this until i got halfway well i
did it
and my hands were like slipping and like
bleeding at the end but like when i
asked
we got to the top and asked ryota what
the [ __ ] is this she's like oh you know
four people died here last year
why are we climbing up here i was in
jeans and just like some silly trainers
just imagine you climbing it with this
hat on and like a pair of vans
and there's like a shot of ryotaro
getting to the cliff edge and his hand
slipping
and it felt a bit like that seeing the
lion king well it's a long lived recruit
i should how long did you have to climb
up this
it took like 15-20 minutes it's quite an
endurance it's quite endurance
you don't like have any safety [ __ ]
i don't know i was trying to film it on
a rucksack i was in jeans so i couldn't
like move my legs past like
20 degrees and they're like what this
isn't funny of death that day yeah
yeah there's a video called japan's most
expensive beef and
he joked we have to do this challenge he
didn't even clickbait it i would know
she's part of another
and then he took me there nearly died
and i was like trying to eat the beef
and shake it
ptsd from this cliff shocked
how did you get down you got to go down
it as well you got to go down at the
same [ __ ] way
you walk all holding onto the chain just
slipping down
how vertical is this thing [ __ ] so
it's like a footpath it's like the light
is like the lion king if you see the
lion king it's like that no way you can
climb a
vertical wall it was it was it was
almost practically vertical
[ __ ] i love how connor's not like
you know suspicious about the story he's
suspicious about your athletic ability
him with a camera no way was this like
during the first journey across japan
kind of era where you had to keep in
shape i suppose
it was i would have been like no this
isn't even funny this isn't like
entertainment this is just death he
didn't even click later so it was it
wasn't
it wasn't in japan how did you not take
one look at it and go like
no that looks dangerous i don't know why
did it take you up until halfway where
you were like this might be dangerous we
had this experienced climber who's
wearing like the most expensive climbing
boots and he sort of went up it really
quick
hmm it can't be that hard and then i got
it and i'm like
holding onto this chain and you know if
you hold on to a metal chain you just
slip down it yeah your hands are greasy
yeah you start to bleed
and it's yeah that it was just awful
really awful for the content dreadful
god for someone who's afraid of danger
you've done you've been in a lot of
dangerous situations i want more you can
do that but not
not going to [ __ ] cave yeah yeah [ __ ]
okay
i want more extreme sports videos i want
to see chris do snowboarding
obviously chris do like the sasuke
challenge like the [ __ ] like
the ninja challenge like the vertical
wall
sasuke challenge yeah it's called sasuke
in japanese
oh it's called the saskatchewan they
just called it the ninja warrior
challenge in a broad japan wheelchair
challenge but i'm done with it
i don't think so
chris trying to go up the vertical wall
it's a trash taste video you should go
to the [ __ ] cliff and climb it
i'm down does the trash stay special i
know we could actually die in this
yeah i think the views gone why not do a
skiing
special but i don't know how you'd film
it it'd be too hard go pros all around
okay i'll do the drone and just sit in
the chair
the challenge is try to learn how to
snowboard which would be my channel yeah
that's true
because i've been on my ass most likely
chris uh had a bit of an accident and
then couldn't ski very well i was doing
all right i didn't skin a few years and
then i just fell over and my leg was
[ __ ] and i just couldn't sleep the
rest of the day oh [ __ ] yeah
it was awful that's dangerous it's
really dangerous i just kept falling
over i was snowboarding down and i was
waiting at the bottom
for chris and i just see this like mini
avalanche forming
a snowball literally like i'm just
watching him and i look at my phone for
one second i look up and i just see
the clouds coming clouds of snow
falling and then and then i'm like oh
[ __ ]
you're right chris but then when you're
at the bottom you're like i can't do
anything yeah he's gotta
stand there come on chris good luck
chris your friend would have climbed up
for me
oh [ __ ] great [ __ ] that he was so far
up i couldn't i couldn't go
how much further did you go down
compared to him didn't wait for him no
so
what it was is that like a true friend
it was kind of like a long extended one
and so i always just try and stay in
view so when it's in when i get to the
bottom of it i'll just wait for the
bottom of the
until the next slope starts and i just
wait at the bottom because chris is
going really slow
i try and stay in view sorry is that
chris my binoculars out there
and then just saw chris coming and then
he just fell down i was just i was
savouring the moment i just feel bad
take that time savoring the injury
was your knee okay afterwards because he
was pretty beaten up on the day i think
yeah i think i didn't stretch very well
before
and then when i fell over like twisted
my leg and then every time i put
pressure on it i was
[ __ ] yeah i know it's because then
take precautions when skiing yeah
be careful don't do a chris don't just
do a crisp don't door chris you end up
like that
everything else was successful
everything the acid bath that was a good
trip
that's a fun trip what's next
next yeah i want to extreme sports with
your videos are you going to climb out
fiji then
i want to yeah that's what we want
stream did you see they opened it but
at the top what yeah they opened it to
the what is it the
the halfway college right oh [ __ ] yeah
apparently
yeah oh that's not worth it so they've
opened all of mount fuji
except the top except the most
interesting part of the department where
everyone wants to get to
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like opening
opening super mario land but only
letting you in the ticket gate
yeah yeah yeah exactly it's really
bizarre i don't know why they just i'd
rather just not over last year's because
it gets really i mean i've climbed it it
gets very crowded at the top
it's not like it's not like a mountain
when you get the top it's just like
waiting for a thing park ride
takes the magic out i can assure you and
uh and they were worried that people
would spread covered up there right as a
result
but it's gotta imagine getting covered
if you've got covered at the top of that
fiji well done yeah
and you've got all the way up there
that's a test in itself yeah that's a
real endurance test right now
yeah no it's a shame though because
there's no point climbing it this year
then yeah not really
not really maybe something like that but
yeah unfortunately next year yeah
unfortunately that would have been fun
climb up krakatoa something
cracker toad
cracker toe is like the biggest volcano
in indonesia
yeah oh i'd watch that yeah
didn't erupt and destroy most of
southeast asia yeah i mean that way it
was
i think it's like why do you sound so
happy about that this is 200 000 years
ago
yeah yeah i think it's like the site of
the biggest volcanic eruption
in like historic i can't do that that's
a runner-up yeah for you guys
crack attack i'll drone it for you again
just one of those
is there anything like you've like yet
to go
uh in terms of like videos for japan
because i feel like again like because i
think
the question came off the idea from it
yeah the question came up of like you
know because we finished doing across
japan three
and we were like oh is it gonna be
obviously i think after the last episode
goes up
i think next week yeah as of this
episode
if you get a diet are you planning
another journey across japan i don't
know we're gonna get asked
i do i might do one day probably next
year if i do it again but like i like to
just sort of do individual episode
challenges now a series it's a lot of
pressure right because i was like
where's your next one
whenever i finish editing it you know
and
it's you know it's quite tricky to put a
series out and then with the series
right everyone's like oh i love the
first episode then you get
oh the second episode's got the third
and then the fourth it's like is this
still going on then the fifth it's like
so like you kind of lose dwindle
generally a little bit you lose a bit of
momentum
right but it's kind of done all right
this series but it kind of like
you just think i'll just do a standalone
episode next time like one like i did an
episode where i went to japan's most
northern extreme point this year that's
just one episode 30 minutes long
and that was kind of fun i see doing
more like standalone almost like a trash
taste special
it's going to steal your format except
it's going to be special
christmas on krakatoa it's going to be
great
what i want to know is like how much
planning goes into journey across japan
because it seems like
what's so funny why is he laughing he's
just picturing climbing krakatoa
it's [ __ ] off with the muscle is it
still there
is it still there it's a [ __ ] volcano
i think it blew up and actually
disappeared
what are you talking about
was so powerful it blew the whole summit
off so it's like mountain i don't think
it's
erupted within our lifetime i think
you're talking about an event that
happened like 200 000 years ago chris
i actually don't know what you're
talking gonna find out we're gonna find
out if it happened two hundred thousand
years ago we probably wouldn't [ __ ]
call it a mountain anymore because you
wouldn't know what it was
like okay there we go all right
it's island okay 1883 it wasn't 200
thousand years ago it was like 200 years
ago i think
my bad because it might be a few times
okay eighteen eighty three sixteen
eighty five you know how good of a
youtube video would have been if your
volcano exploded while you were in the
session it did explode didn't it after
we flew over it
later sakurajim is the most active
volcano in japan it smokes 24 hours a
day and then
about a week after we flew over it
actually erupted yeah and if we
our plane had been going over it it
would have been like just swatted out
the sky yeah
it was pretty [ __ ] scary yeah the
pilot was quite good he was like a
military pilot and that could be a great
video he was like
yeah yeah it was a little bit dangerous
like a couple people died all right i'm
pretty sure not
that day
[Laughter]
i don't hope so did you see someone die
just like we still filming this
we're still going guys in the town like
built right next to the volcano yeah
there's a there's lots of there's you
know thousands of people live around the
base that feels like a
bad idea it's pretty safe the kids have
to wear helmets to protect them from ash
and things but
everybody's like an acid bath and a
electric
onsen between a spicy bath and a
active volcano it's like 10 to 100 ways
to kill yourself with glory this episode
isn't it
that's the taxes 100 ways to die
thank you very much do they have a plan
for if the volcano goes off
well the people are safe because they're
sort of just
like far away enough from it but it used
to be an island sakurajima
and then it erupted and became a
peninsula because the lava just
connected with the land and built a land
bridge
so it's a pretty pretty hardcore volcano
too much volcano some would say
asr it's not krakatoa isn't it
yeah because like you always seem to
like find some really like really out
there ideas cool ideas for
not just joining across japan but just
in general and these guys are talking
about how you literally
like [ __ ] scour google maps or
something yeah i mean
what goes into that there's definitely
variables in jail across japan like we
have a kind of start and end place we
have the hotel at the beginning of the
end
and then have a few locations lined up
um and then i sort of keep it from
in this season i kept it from joey
natsuki yeah then we get challenges
then the challenges shape what happens
right so the day we did the rap too much
volcano we could have done anything it
could have been like
eat the worst food in kumamoto or you
know something like that so there's lots
of variables that keeps it
fresh and original but when you've got a
team of like five people
and you know it's a very pricey
experience to make you've got to make
sure that
you're actually doing good things right
yeah you know so various places are
planned out but i wouldn't say it's
scripted as such no no i feel journey
across japan three though was like
way more intense than two like i feel i
just feel like that week
of three was just we did i reckon twice
as much stuff as we did in two
years at least that's what it felt like
to me just ask myself how could you make
like the ultimate series in a week
and that's pretty much all the stuff i
found led to that so how long did it
take in total like
to find all those places oh like planned
out
and all that okay three days
three days 72 hours no i did actually
spend like two or three days just glued
to google like [ __ ] what is that i i
spend more time trying to plan my
[ __ ] holiday
you just planned and an entire [ __ ]
special five like five day special
i think the greatest find was this
abandoned island called ikishima
um there's like a the the abandoned
island everyone knows nagasaki's
gunkanjima battleship island
you've probably seen this because you
can't [ __ ] do anything there well
yeah
yeah we i i thought you could walk
around it but you can only go ninety
percent of it is blocked off
so he only goes a tour and that was
gonna be the centerpiece of the series
so once i discovered that i was like
we're [ __ ] and i got really
depressed and i was like is even worth
doing this series now the lost islands
it's not gonna work is it it's gonna be
the boring island so i kept looking
around nagasaki and i found
just 40 kilometers north another island
bigger ten times bigger than gunkanjima
thirty abandoned buildings like a city a
mini city and uh less than a hundred
people
and a hundred yeah hundred percent
people live there and you can explore it
freely really cool it did look really
cool that was my kind of
probably my favorite episode actually so
what's like your process of finding
these places because i would like to
know because
like i you know i i would like to travel
around more around japan but i
literally don't know where to [ __ ]
start like you do a google search about
cool places to go in japan you get like
the same
shinjuku you should get the same 10
articles with the same
like 20 places every [ __ ] article you
just pick a place
like a place you want to go to and then
you start looking at everything around
the area right
well i'll switch to japanese use
japanese to search gets a lot easier
right because obviously the people that
know the places are going to be in japan
japanese and so
if you do that you'll find like 10 times
more interested places otherwise it's
just always tourist hot spots
yeah basically that's my advice get
someone who can speak japanese to look
up to these places
now to just find that japanese person
yeah joey
joey planning the next trash day special
yeah sure
this episode is sponsored by hong kong
pack the third a free-to-play 3d action
role-playing mobile game developed and
published by mihoyo
the same makers of genshin impact boys
the folks over at hawkeye impact the
third actually have a massive
announcement to me
oh my god what is it joey oh the
characters you love from genji and
impact such as fishel
and kaching will be making their way
into the world of hong kong
no way i'm so excited right now i am
practically [ __ ] visual and a
companion aussie will be the new
valkyrie to join hongkai her powerful
thunder attribute ability makes fishel
invincible
in the new world for kaching players
will be able to free powerful forces for
her to fight against such as the
powerful wolf
of the north and both fischel and
kaching are both free characters
too right that's high that's high right
now furthermore
right now new players who join the game
can win over 100 free supply cards to
get different equipment by completing
missions in-game if you're living in the
us or canada they're also doing a
collaboration with kung fu tea a popular
bubble bubba tea brand join the event to
win limited merch
and an iphone 12. and if you're not in
the u.s or canada boys
you guys honkey impact sweepstakes on
their site to win a big
mystery prize what kind of prize is it
it's a mystery joey
hence mystery prize what's in the box
so what are you waiting for download
hong kong at the third today and join
the event to win some great prizes
links and info in the description down
below and back to the episode
so as you can see we've just popped out
the uh umeshu now you mentioned
chris's request that an alcoholic
beverage be consumed on trash taste this
is my
drinks drink of choice but a lot of my
japanese friends are like oh girls drink
really i'm like sake i thought you're
the i do that we have sake this is
really
refreshing right like plum wine they
take a plum put in some sake leave it
there [ __ ] them
well how much are you supposed to pour
in i don't normally drink something
pretty purified
yeah okay so about to find
cheers cheers to best drip wherever i am
barely most english most drip
says the guy that a minute ago off
camera went i have dentists
he didn't say hey listen
some words are unknown he's got dentists
all over his face i thought he just went
to the dentist as well
what's up with that because then i
haven't been in like five years
do you have dentists i haven't been like
an issue you need to sort out or you
want to make a mold because my
my uh why why is that so [ __ ] funny
chris it's
a [ __ ] mold what nothing funny about
chad
absolutely i don't know there's nothing
funny
he's losing it what happened that's one
simple
message
what the [ __ ] was it again it was like
i remember supposed to be on viewership
no there's there's this hate comment
that chris shared with me about
it so this sounds like he was raised on
risotto and wise
from the breast or something i hate this
guy he sounds like he was served on
risotto from the breast
and one wine before milk it was quite
you know it felt like
i was like instead of baby food it was a
risotto baby
have we talked about the japan dentist
experience we haven't because
what is that i went to an english
dentist oh again
meline was like yeah they speak all
english and they use american practices
that are better than japan are they
better than japanese
the american way apparently is better
than the japanese apparently japanese
dentists have a bad rep i've heard
they're pretty bad it's it's not that
they're bad like i went the other day
it's a japanese one and it's like it's
not that they're bad it's just they're a
lot more like
ruthless when it comes to like cleaning
your teeth like you know because they
use that like
really like tiny thin like high pressure
waterhole
and it kind of makes it type of sound i
hate that
yeah they use that right like all
dentists do but they go
like hard they just like just they could
say
they sound really nice when they're like
asking you to open your mouth right like
i didn't realize like japanese dentists
had a bad rap but it makes sense now the
first time i went to a dentist japanese
dentist he said don't worry i learned in
canada
it's like a exact case it's like a it's
an advertising point if you're training
yeah in america or so they're all
trained in canada and they
may be front and center of their
marketing yeah because
american dental uh system is actually
pretty good if you can afford it
which is yeah always there's the cash
that's the biggest yikes um
but yeah no it's really good i mean i
i've because you know
no one tells you you've got to go to the
dentist by the way until until your
teeth are like [ __ ] you're like i
guess i should go dentist
so i just totally forgot to go to the
dentist for how long it's like five
years
five years without dentists people like
you that create the big book of british
spanish
4k no they were all right i never had
problems and
they i went and they were like so why
are you going twice so um i
when my when i jet like when my mouth is
resting my like bite is pretty deep
like it i mean you have this as well
right yeah yeah so just to stop my teeth
from grinding in my sleep why are you
laughing like a rabid dog
no it's just like when you're resting
you know some people when you rest it's
i think it's when you have like a
particular shape it's kind of yeah when
i sleep it's kind of uncomfortable
to close my mouth yeah what do you dream
about to make you do that
are you like written off of the [ __ ]
you're dreaming about playing apex raid
of shadows in your sleep
shadows he makes real shadows
there's about four games in one
apex raid of shadows my favorite game
you're in touch with the kids right
try and be a [ __ ] boomer on purpose
on [ __ ] person you play that apex
rate of shadows bridge of the youth
today on
all the games really i know apex right
of shadows
i heard connor showed you uh league of
legends esports the other day
do you remember that yeah when i was um
when we went to uh we filmed that
trailer
the movie trailer and oh my god i can
only imagine chris watching lee
you know chris was editing away and the
massive
70-inch tv was not being used and i was
like well great i'll just put the league
of legends esports on
no you showed me a guy from north
england who just eats food all day i did
show you that as well i've called rape
my takeaway youtube channel it's just a
guy from north england who eats bringing
it to you
she showed me that one as well yeah
she's like the top
like the most popular british channel
right now it's just some guy eating
takeaway guys
she's cracking love i love my beard it's
beautiful he has a little chair and a
table he goes like a fish and chip shop
gets the fish and chips and just sits
out on the road
yeah and people know him he's famous now
so wow that was a fish and chips there
like and he's like yes goodnight
this is one video and it's the funniest
thing we're used to a chinese takeaway
and um he opens his box up and nothing
in it looks
like chinese food yeah it's like chips
and wings and stuff and it's all just
cracking
it's amazing and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is
this but everything he tries he loves he
loves it he's great he's really just
fun yeah he's just great kind of like
kind of like northern british report of
the week
in spanish that sounds awesome yeah
basically yeah
i mean that's essentially that is what
it is uh rate my takeaway trash taste
collapse that's what we need
if he comes over here that would be the
video i would love to see him you might
just go to the ramen shop he just takes
it outside they're like no no no
i don't know he gets his little shared
table out
i'd love that yeah so i did show him
that but yeah on the big screen i showed
you league of legends and you were so
confused
there's just lots of commentators going
it's like the red bull baron player
chris reacts to league of legends
esports just what do you think of it
[ __ ] they sponsor they sponsor this
everything oh i love them
on their show they have like you know
when they have like the best moment of
the game it's called the mercedes drive
to victory yeah
what yeah and it's sponsored by mercedes
drive to victory
yeah that's the like clip and they have
the red bull barrel
the red ball baron power play what else
is there the state farm analyst desks
yeah the analyst desk where they talk
about and then they have the mastercard
stats or something yeah the mastercard
something i don't
know does anyone remember battlefield
1942
that was a great game and uh yeah so we
i got i got christian to league of
legends esports
he's a massive fan there he loves it now
who what team do you root for
in league of shadows uh
what is it with you and shadows why do
you like that word so much
apex reign of shadows league of shadows
my favorite team in the wizards the
wizards
what's the last game you played chris it
was the last video what's the last video
game
tetris oh red dead redemption 2.
did you like that yeah it's cracking i
don't have the word shadow in it though
what's your top five video games of all
time
uncharted four okay come on and conquer
generals
okay battle from there perfect dark
nintendo 64.
i think they don't know even though it's
difficult to play now yeah i can't
really see what's going on screen no
that's my eyes that's mostly in 64. that
was so great
yeah and uh mario kart double dash
that's right it's actually not about
this with a cheeky bit of resident four
thrown in
oh oh oh so i've got some games
you know all the stuff we talked about
are you saying go outside
is saying is touch grass philosophy with
abroad in japan
i feel like life is an rpg isn't it in
japan
you unlock quest by meeting people you
nearly die on a cliff
with a chain you know a plane over a
volcano you get all those experiences
in that and then you go home and watch
league of shadows yeah
i just didn't see the thrill of it
there's just lots of people on screen
commentating that like
[Music]
that's generally what happened yeah yeah
that's what most sports games are like
you're saying
let's give the poor people a chance to
play
i was in the cadets the raf cadets clay
pigeon did you did you see that
what's what's the only more white and
posh thing i could think of
[Music]
synchronization
[Music]
barely fuji that's a sport
listen to you right
[Music]
[Music]
yeah how did that happen i just wanted
to get fit really and at the university
oh university right all the cool kids
are doing it i'll join in how long do
you think
i've got quite a few i did it did a year
got like a yellow belt
is that high i i i think yellow belt is
one afterlife
[Laughter]
it's like level two i could kill you
with one foot
if you're already asleep if you put your
weight on there
it looks like it's [ __ ] happening
here right
but uh yeah my sporty days behind me
as we've established you just sound like
somebody's giving up
i don't do exercises i am taking a day
like a physical challenge though like
like journey across japan again and
maybe like walking or it's a good excuse
to
get into shape right yeah yeah yeah i
find that i can't get into shape without
a goal
well i genuinely thought i was going to
climb out fuji this year until that came
out
because i thought how hard is it to
climb mount fuji as someone who's never
climbed mount fuji and someone who's
like obviously thinking about doing it i
did it when i was 22
and sorry 23 and yeah it was pretty
tricky jesus
23 and you something you still found it
tricky it wasn't fun
i'm [ __ ] then it wasn't funny it
wasn't no no
a moment of it was fun great i'm looking
forward to running around
brilliant i slept on a rock because when
the clever people that climb out fuji
you start at 5 p.m right yeah you climb
[ __ ] buddhist monk or something like
yes this is this is your bed for today
you've got to sleep on the moon
huts at like 9 p.m they were all full
yeah and they're like no
no no room i was like oh [ __ ] you then
and i literally found like a small rock
that could just i could just pop my head
on and i
like got my jumper and i made it into a
pillow and slept outside
yeah were you not cold frozen yeah i was
about to say isn't that how people die
yeah my friend went in t-shirt and
shorts and nearly got frostbite it was
really serious actually
[ __ ] idiots we got to the top the sun
came up and we gotta go now we can't
enjoy it unfortunately
all that climb was for nothing we waited
for the sun to come up came up i'm like
all right good we'll see it let's go
but did you guys do no research before
climbing right
and uh did you think it was a hill or
something well
i mean it was it was about you know
fujino shores and a t-shirt so we did it
in the summer and it was about 36
degrees outside
yeah you think well it's going to be hot
on top yeah it's going to be cold on top
but it's not really that cold
but it is almost 4 000 meters yeah we
got started climbing it and my friend
turned up his t-shirt and shorts the
japanese people like what are you doing
[ __ ] idiot
and they're like you were very stupid
white people yeah
and like that and we were like oh
they're on about it can't be that bad
and then as we got up it went like 18
degrees 12 degrees 5 degrees minus 2
degrees
and you know my friend was like at one
point
sounds like something ominous was going
on in the dark but like
what really happened on the rock
the hat was brought for that um
you can you can take it off now i want
the best trip
take a ski jacket yeah take some pillows
take your [ __ ] gamer aid and you're
good to go
you knew your broad and japan special
right hypothermia challenge right
[Laughter]
on the rock win ten thousand dollars
last one to leave the rock wins ten
thousand dollars but then after all that
it just got demonetised because i put
like some music from um
was that the band with the shamisen uh
the yoshida brothers oh yeah i just got
taken off
so you can't watch it in japan it got
completely demand and my friend norm
the cameraman virginia across japan
plays with the gosh brothers
he didn't nothing happened bastard and
uh
yeah nothing it was number one
mount fuji video for like two years
before it got buggered that's just gone
who's number one now
that's a good question who's who's
number one on mount fuji
if you look up mount fuji killer
[Music]
what if it's just like chris's other
video probably i should just take that
video and just edit it and repost it
is it still chris it's still crazy oh
chris what are you what are you
complaining about chris
still still the top video happiest day
of my life i've won an award i've got a
message
i can't think of a more british thing
than trying to clown trying to climb
mount fuji shorts and a t-shirt right
it's pretty brilliant
like in england you see sunshine it's
like all right it could be like
15 16 degrees you see a bit of sun
shorts and t-shirts time right it's hard
to imagine like when you stand outside
36 degrees it's hard to think there's
nowhere in this country that could be
cold enough you need something like that
right yeah so you know you go from
central tokyo shinjuku where we started
to mount fuji two-hour bus ride and then
bang it's like
you might not just think like maybe i
should just give a quick google as to
what goes on on mount food maybe i
should check the weather yeah see what
goes on
you know what do people reckon well i
mean i i did have a ski kind of ski
jacket and shorts
yeah my friend went in just t-shirt you
didn't tell your friend
i i did i did he was right
was he british oh yeah oh yeah okay he
was not
surprised you're able to sleep in that
[ __ ] cold with didn't really i
remember
just hell why don't you just carry on to
the top
i guess you're so battered by that point
fair enough and you're not supposed to
a lot of the clever people do something
called bullet climbing or that's not
really clever
when you get to the base there's
something a sign is saying don't bullet
climb
the book climb is where you rush up the
mountain as quick as you can like you
know five six hours
yeah you come back down but like a lot
of people get towards the top
the oxygen deprivation kicks in they
sort of just pass out and just
get [ __ ] up so we're supposed to do it
kind of slowly to acclimatize to the
lack of oxygen yeah i got a lot of good
friends that do it in one morning go up
get there the afternoon come back down
and i'd probably do that if i was gonna
do it again i'd probably just do that
the sunset was great but it's like it's
playing like a combination there just a
nightmare to stay in on the
accommodation
yeah let's get booked up very quick yeah
that's pretty bad yeah
how do you got to like know people to
get accommodation there
um and i didn't know that the
alternative was just sleeping on a rock
but i guess
now i know paul monk did you sleep on
the mountain
i don't have much choice i think it's
recommended it's in the dark it's pitch
black up there
you can't you can't see ryan i went off
the track a little bit and just found a
volcanic rock slept on it
job done
it's volcanic it's it's kind of warm
laughing at me for my lack of sports
when i've slept on a rock
straight from crack at all from crack
i'll be impressed by your stupidity
why would i be impressed by that i'll
just wait until i climb crackatera we'll
see you as the last laugh
you're gonna climb anything i don't know
how tall it is
it's probably very tall something else
to find out but
yeah i think it's like the biggest
volcano in the world right now i don't
know what
it's like top 10 volcanoes yeah is it
i think so it's definitely one of the
most famous volcanoes in the world
i'd never what the [ __ ] is going on why
say volcano so it promotes his new
[ __ ] song hey i'm okay with that i'm
in it
yeah go to itunes give me five percent
and i'll show it
well we're gonna we're gonna [ __ ]
sponsor you
sponsored by too much volcano but like
yeah no i i'm running out of
really cool kind of cool things to do in
japan you've done everything well how
many how many prefectures do you have
left you said like four
i've got two prefectures to go to two
prefectures yeah what are they
uh koti in shikoku and
miyazaki which we kind of drove through
onto the drawers
can we kill that no no no no i kind of
feel like we should know
do you feel like you've almost completed
japan i've got
my i've got a scratch map of japan right
of course i do i like scratch every time
i go i'm like yeah i'm going that
prefecture
and it's got like only a few bits to
scratch off now and then i'll be like
done
what are you gonna do yeah what are you
gonna do after that bits and pieces of
okinawa the pacific islands of japan
like algoshima
have you ever seen it it looks like it
looks like yeah
[Laughter]
now you start doing soap land reviews
[Music]
scratch the last one
on the summit of mount fuji like [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i think but there's
still lots of places in prefectures you
know i've only
passed through some of these preferences
and there's still lots of things to see
and do
is it getting hard to find video topics
though or you still feel like you're
trying to find this there's still an
endless amount like i only just made a
video
yesterday on asakusa the district in
tokyo really the most tourists in japan
go to
it's the most popular sport awful and
when there's tourists there it can't be
yeah
but it's a beautiful part is [ __ ]
horrible when there's tourists
the shrine right yeah yeah senior temple
you also like can't take pictures of
that and post them online
were filming and the security guards
sort of wandered up and just came into
shop behind us
and we were like oh [ __ ] we can't film
here yeah luckily we got away with it
just in time before we turned up
apparently you get fined though
well if you post it so we'll see bring
it up
yeah you don't think there's like
hundreds of tourists taking pictures of
it right yeah because like the eiffel
tower is
like private property that you
technically i you know you can't
actually take pictures of
really for commercial use but they do
all the time because
yeah it's just a [ __ ] answer there's
nothing stopping them right yeah i mean
you can't regulate that it's it's it's
literally in the skyline well japan is
like
bet we're gonna try and raise about
filming laws like have you ever been to
a japanese concert
or japanese like you've been to a
concert but i haven't what
you think you film them do they no no no
no no no no no no they don't let you
film it yeah
it's really like looked down upon to
like film
a concert a live concert whereas to be
honest and
live in the moment i'm pretty good about
actually well you can't even like relive
the moment
yourself when i when i did the
documentary on hyde the rockstar guy
nobody took out their phone you can see
no one apart from the end when he gets
everyone out to put the lights on their
phone
yeah sea of light they're pretty damn
strict on that
it's it's so that they i don't mind that
though but the reason they do that is so
that they get you to buy
the dvd yeah yeah yeah yeah right so
it's like
just a promotional spiritual javascript
no i don't appreciate the artist
yeah you have to live in the moment
let's just buy your [ __ ] message
it's literally better max of this the
hide credit cards
what merchandise is off the charts what
the [ __ ] i used so much money from it i
was really impressed
well yeah he's selling [ __ ] credit
where's the abroad in japan
we've got top 14 itunes
perfect the entire card is just it's
just that face
i got approached by a company once to
make a natsuki doll
and you'd squeeze it and be like go [ __ ]
yourself
why did you not say yes that sounds like
a genius i don't know i don't know i
didn't want to exploit natsuki
i think he wanted that i think that i
asked him he's like yeah why haven't we
done it
yeah so i might still do it i might
still do it and also now you've said it
now
you're never going to hear the answer
you don't want the natsuki delty ladies
and gentlemen
they are you kidding me
yeah go [ __ ] yourself it needs to be
like you squeeze it and it's like yeah
it's like a random
quotes right 20 quotes that's easy why
would you not do that it's such low
hanging fruit they wanted to take over
all my merchandise and i said no
oh okay so i thought well i'll steal
that idea
differently i'm sure you could find a
manufacturer i can do that for you
somebody help me
email me so yeah sorry you we got an
attention because you're talking about
filming in uh
i said i talked about merchandise
yeah so i mean there's still places that
i've been to that are very
easy picking so that's it yeah i feel
like japan is just like a [ __ ] gold
mine of
weird and wonderful places i just like
to find the kind of unique stuff
yeah yeah i went to a place with just
replica easter island heads in
hokkaido like 20 easter island yeah yeah
yeah
it's a cemetery how can we respect the
dead
easter island heads and it kind of it's
pretty cool
and it's like to scale it look normal
they had a massive face mask on it
so your this video is just like about
the area
but yeah pretty much just is it harder
to do that when there's so many
interesting things in a place
where you're like fine that seems like a
video id you would have done like we
tried
so i did with ryotaro we tried to find
retro places kind of unique places that
are kind of
old showa era places yeah did you wear a
kimono
you bet i didn't i like you didn't use
yeah so when we went to do the the
kawari smashing which is right next to
sakta kaho was like let's just wear
kimonos
it didn't look worryingly good on me
thanks man in a way that i can't do
because it just makes me look around
you'd look like a land baron it would
shoot you
i would oh yes my property is just over
here
like kimonos looks so bad on me every
time i do a video well people sometimes
will get annoyed about it as well which
is really [ __ ] stupid i think
oh well because it's like appropriation
or whatever right yeah
you know i did look at that photo of you
and think cultural appropriation
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah of course i mean you know it's one
of those things where i i feel like if
you're not being a [ __ ] and not
running around or spilling [ __ ] on it
yeah yeah
i think the only time i was in the sort
of cultural appropriation camp on that
front was when um
kim kardashian kimono underwater and
like you know you could
you could see a future 10 years down the
line had she followed through where like
kids might have been like oh yeah the
kimonos
king kardashian's brand yeah yeah any
historical context or cultural context
about it i agree with that
i'd consider cultural appropriation yeah
absolutely yeah and just full-blown
country
yeah and uh yeah i was kind of like
loads of japanese women like don't
take up don't take that name and then
ruin it yeah and i was like yeah that's
fair enough yeah absolutely i i often
find that
especially in asian countries people
like people here seem to like
are happy to have you kind of adopt
their culture yeah i would love it
i mean that's that's how like the whole
nihongo jozu thing really like happened
right because you speak one word of
japanese and everyone's just like
nihongo jozu well done you've been part
of our culture finally
it's funny right because it's to us now
we here like to explain
whenever you speak like any japanese
like to like
you could be ordering food or something
right and a japanese person will say
nihongo josu even if you just [ __ ]
said like you said if you said arigato
or something in the worst japanese
accent they would say like
oh nihongo jozu but like i i feel like
they do that because they're just like
so
happy that a foreigner took the time to
like
learn that they're like why would they
learn our language yeah yeah and i feel
i feel like it's just
it's it's more towards like asian
culture in general because did i tell
you guys that i got
like tai zhouz here in japan
no okay so i did i didn't even know that
we could get tai josu right
um but like yeah i was like yeah it
sounds like a martial
he wasn't literally thai josie but like
i didn't even i didn't even think about
it because like
younger jose is like kind of a meme for
anyone foreign living in japan because
we hear it so [ __ ] often
um and so i went to a thai restaurant uh
in japan
and uh you know it was flee thai
restaurant thai staff
thai cook and everything and i was like
great phil just like homie authentic
shoot the authentic [ __ ] right oh yeah
and so uh the waitress comes to take my
order
and i order uh patra power and green
curry gang kyoguan
uh and she goes uh thai gang magna
which which is the closest thing i could
uh
which equivalent of nihongo jose which
is like thai equivalent to
tai jozu and i was like i didn't even
know that this could be a thing until i
heard it and i'm just like
i'm tired lady i literally just [ __ ]
ordered a green curry
i would like a bad time
but like yeah i think about it and it's
just because especially in thailand or
in japan
people are just happy to like and and to
just
any foreigners kind of adopting their
language or having a go at like that
culture or whatever
it's strange isn't it because like the
opposite doesn't really work for like
english-speaking countries
i mean i i get very excited when anyone
mentions whales in any capacity outside
of chris
have you seen cultural appropriation of
whales [ __ ] sheep what do you mean
you can't really i mean i just if anyone
shows any interest in it i'm like oh
that's awesome but like
you don't see like you know a japanese
couple going to the uk
and then going up you know going to
[ __ ] tescos and being like
hello and they're going oh your english
is so [ __ ] good
it's funny they go around like the
castles and just take pictures yeah all
right i guess that is pretty cool i'll
tell you i'm quarter welsh by the way
no you're not i'm one of your people no
you're not twenty-five percent you're
not one of me my grandfather
i refuse i refuse to believe it
i reject family name is pew p-u-g-h oh
god that is actually wild
i'm lucky we're the same you're
basically related this is what happens
straight from the path of wales you
become a christian
you escape you become a cultural
approach you become
how did you feel going to that royal
welsh city it's pretty
well i think it's awesome you know
because the you know unlike japanese
like welsh culture
got like [ __ ] obliterated by the
english they pretty much they made it
like almost illegal
to speak welsh in wales for a very long
time you get punished if you spoke well
so
i you know when there's anything kind of
even remotely well i should get quite
proud because i'm like
nobody gives a [ __ ] so it's awesome who
gives a [ __ ] yeah because it's so weird
because
normally when people think of whales
they just think of like the uk in
general
it's like it is very difficult anyways
yeah you know we still have greg's we
still have betfred
depressing [ __ ] but like the houses look
very different most of the time
depending on where you go you know i
mean people forget that whales have
just their own language yeah yeah yeah
people some people think it's a city in
england for [ __ ] sake which is
depressing
well i think there was a quiz that they
asked like americans
about famous english towns and where
they kept listing wales as a city
some people in this survey oh no you
know i mean like because
it doesn't happen in scotland everyone
knows scotland everyone knows ireland
because everyone in [ __ ] america
insists they're irish
yeah exactly so it doesn't happen but
like that nobody gets nobody's well she
nobody gives a [ __ ]
about it so it's really good to see what
someone does yeah yeah the only time i
ever got any conversation about it was
then people watched the [ __ ] crown
and they were like oh he spoke that
funny language that you speak in that in
the third season
i'm like thanks got like one episode
they [ __ ] off and they never spoke
about it again
it was like one of the most depressing
episodes it's still [ __ ] depressing
yeah
yeah it's weird it's weird that's pretty
it's pretty [ __ ] tragic we have a
prince of wales it doesn't come to
[ __ ] whales
i mean you must be in the top 10 most
successful welsh people in the world
out of 17 aren't you i said that's a
depressing thought isn't it
[Laughter]
you're up there with tom james probably
no no no no
no no i mean i don't know any other
welshman catherine zeta-jones
christian christian gareth male sorry
chris christian bale is yeah but he's
like a weird kind of uh
i think he's well is he welsh i think he
is i think he's born in wales but raised
in london
anthony hopkins andy hopkins christopher
ellis the guy who plays lucifer
oh really he's walsh from college you're
up there with them see all these people
yes hopkins oscar-winning actor and
c-dog v8 member of the trash station
podcast
that's the winner of the trash i thought
all those people are british
if you go to uh you go to anthony
hopkins twitter he's always tweeting
really i think he speaks welsh i think
so oh because he's always tweeting him
does he follow you on twitter
sadly that's the goal i thought i get
verified
yeah when you get verified all right you
earned it this episode is sponsored by
crunchyroll crunchyroll just kicked off
the new slate of anime of the summer
season not only will the service host
continuing classics like my hero
academia baruto and one piece but this
season is stacked with the return of the
popular series like miss kobayashi's
dragon maid
s tokyo revenges to your eternity and
that time i got reincarnated as a slime
season 2. watch it all on crunchyroll
right now you can watch titles for free
or try a 14 day free trial of a premium
membership to skip the ads and access
stimulu casting simulcast
what chris meant to say was cybercasting
in japan
just follow the links in the description
below to start watching today
top picks for new titles this season
including girlfriend's girlfriend
fenner pirate princess and remake our
life episode 1 of remake our life and
girlfriend's girlfriends are already
live on crunchyroll
you can try out a 14 day free trial of
crunchyroll premium by going to our link
crunchyroll.com
trash taste that's crunchyroll.com trash
taste i hope you'll enjoy
all the anime cruise i love girlfriend
girlfriend
what do i have to do to get verified i
mean how didn't you get identified no
you're not verifying the instagram
immediately given that you have an
article coming out every week about you
and your
your guidance yeah what the [ __ ] when
you're how did you fail
how did what did you submit i submitted
they were like submit an article or a
wikipedia page
wikipedia because there were like 25
articles linkedin right
did wikipedia submission for
verification yeah and god did the
articles
because i didn't have a wikipedia dance
the only one who got it yeah
it's wild though you know not to like
anyone but i see people with like 10 000
followers
who have like one acting credit get
verified i mean because if you look at
the uh
it's really bizarre yeah if you look at
the specs that you need to get verified
it's like
you literally have to have like a page
in imdb instant verification or
yeah i do yeah or like anytime
yeah but like a wikipedia i think it's
just like anyone can write a
picture yeah yeah trustee's podcast is
an imdb listed show
yeah but didn't get twitter but didn't
get twitter verified yeah
can't believe it so now it's now my goal
is to get trash chase verified before
you and you
yeah you probably succeed well well if
you failed so now i have a
average chance we have to wait a month
let's find a chance to reapply before
state is on the fccj now yeah yeah
exactly that's
that's that's what we got to submit
right exactly oh good god just submit
that video and we're good
the dream is we're all verified and
chris isn't yeah that that that would
truly
become a reality this month because when
i when chris hit 2 million subscribers
on youtube and i hadn't hit two million
yet he never let me hear the end of it
every time he did anything any time
something happened to chris would be
like two million subs in it they just
want two million subs
why do you get the big bed two million
subscribers
[Laughter]
will all get there we'll all get there
soon enough i'll make it only it's it
will all get there eventually it's a
matter of who first
right because we all know with how old
this [ __ ] goes
whoever gets verified first the other
person will not hear the end of it yeah
i do i i would rather end my youtube
career than have chris vera
chris you can you can apply for it
before i can yeah
you've got a trick big chance yeah but
if i what if i don't get it again i hope
you don't
yeah because if he gets it i am never
going to hit the other i'm going to use
my
contacts book to meet jack dawg
it's a great contact book i'm going to
meet jack dawes if you like don't get
cwa
verified yeah right the only thing i
have above chris right now
that i'm twitter verified if you could
have uh rang up jack
dorsey to get me not verified why didn't
you ring him up to get you verified
he's a busy man don't want to take it
because jack's like one at a time one at
a time
which do you prefer are you verified or
chris oh conor not verified chris is the
kind of guy who would rather be like
conor not there yeah yeah
it's disappointing but yeah that's gonna
happen all right you'll get there you'll
get there eventually one time when i was
a kid
go on i didn't realize rams were
dangerous rams yeah rams are pretty
[ __ ] dangerous
rams what's france what's that [ __ ]
it's a ram
what's ram oh you mean like a like a
male
sheep oh i no wait no that's not around
no no it's not
what's the ram
random access memory it's like a sheep
that looks like a she looks like a sheep
but it's
the sheep with like the massive like
curly horns oh
and you've been having a girl knowledge
you didn't know
what do we call those creatures that ram
into things i i didn't know they were
dangerous
when i was a kid you didn't it's called
a ram yeah i bet you when you're a kid
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're you're you're you're that's what
a sheep right
i was like disney and [ __ ] so i just
thought every animal was like kind and
[ __ ]
except for like tigers and stuff but i
was like we don't do that so
i thought it was uh we don't know tigers
of wales well in england you're kind of
taught that
like nothing's dangerous you should be
able to like
chill out with the sheep and like just
hang out with them when you're a kid
just kind of pet them and stuff
so i went into like this like gated off
thing that was full of ram
right like 20 of them i started feeding
them grass like in front of them like in
the cage
you just got [ __ ] no they just left me
alone but then when i was doing it i was
like i don't know why i'm telling the
story but i was like 15 ram
around me i'm just feeding them grass
picking it up and then some guy
some like really really uh igloos what
the hell are you doing in that cage
and it's reminded me of chris
young man what are you doing in this
cage
sorry it's just sake yeah yeah and they
apparently apparently they
they could easily have killed me so wow
oh yeah easily they're pretty [ __ ]
dangerous
how because they ram you with their
horns yeah they're like stomp on you and
like
ram i didn't think there was anything in
the [ __ ] uk that could like any
wildlife in the uk though there are
people
capable of die to cows you know do
they people yeah the cows cows can kill
you they work but they can
how what if calvin just lies on you well
yeah
what if you're just you know like
sleeping what are
and it will literally just go like
douche it won't it will no it won't it
will
as well will rip your hand clean off
like if you feed them like [ __ ] off
well don't kidding me in their mouth
well don't shove your hand into a cow's
mouth are you surprised you want people
to see a cow and just want to feed it
[ __ ]
with that light hand
20 people died last year anything can
kill you yeah
anything can technically kill you but
i'm not small i'm not like having a nap
under a cow and like hoping it does
you're more likely to die
from a cow than a plane
i have nothing to add to this don't
[ __ ] feed a cow don't be a [ __ ]
you might die that's why we don't freak
out
talking about animals that are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
were we talking about that i i just
we're going with this weird [ __ ]
tangent now
but why does [ __ ] everyone idolize
swans or like
why why are swans do they i don't know
i'm pretty sure swanson
is like pretty [ __ ] violent yeah okay
because like every because i grew up
like you know i i grew up no no i grew
up with
this image that you know swans were
these majestic [ __ ] birds they're the
queen's bird you know
like you know isn't it true that like
the queen owns everything yeah every
swan
yeah yeah but there's such [ __ ]
laughing there well
they're like geese like you know they
like they look fine
swans have you seen their mouths
it's like like a serrated like cylinder
it's terrifying
swans and nerfed geese
no because like swansea like i remember
my first memory of the swan because i
thought it was just like a
like a beautiful looking duck and like
ducks are cool ducks yeah bugs are nice
ducks are cute as [ __ ] so as like a
four-year-old kid i remember like
looking at the swan i was like that kind
of looks like a duck like let's let's
let's let's try phoenix
see what happens like so i get close to
it with like the bird food
[ __ ] starts like [ __ ] jabbing my
nose and like [ __ ] attacking me i
love it when they like open their wings
i don't know why it just reminded me of
that video you showed me what was it
called it was like the video title was
literally called
uh ducks annihilating a bowl of peas
it's literally just what the video says
it's like this 30 second video of this
guy with just a bowl of peas
and these two ducks come and then they
literally annihilate this ball like
like it's just the word annihilated
because you're like because you're like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
ducks can't annihilate a bowl of peas
and you see this video like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
violated it please look it up it's
hilarious
i knew how to get away from krakatoa
ducks eating some peas what do you want
to talk about chris what are you talking
about that's not crack at all
don't know anymore i just don't know
what's been on your mind lately
everything
tell me what's been on damage
agony aunt connor i don't think so the
worst agony aren't he's the [ __ ]
uncle agony uncle more like
me yeah horrible
what what what what animal are you
afraid of [ __ ]
i don't know because to me it sounds
like you're afraid of every animal i'm a
no
yeah anything could kick you in the face
and it'll probably hurt
and it can lie on you and you'd probably
die
one is more likely to kill your horse
kicking your face or a cow lying
on you who scared ways to die by
farmyard animals
the debate that needs to happen pigs
with shotguns now
ridiculous can peace kill you what
can
angry pigs
[Music]
angrier hairier pigs when are you gonna
kill a bear on abroad in japan
yeah you bought that you did half the
process there you should have done it
yourself
okay
i don't think that would last very long
to be honest my track record
well i mean because you wait because how
did you have the beer
like how was it prepared that just
terminator bear did it
and it started going into a military
base and they had to take it down it's
like a [ __ ] hollywood movie
seriously military
who will win
the brown bears are terrifying like they
just mean people like a whole campsite
got eaten once
people sleep there there comes a
well-coordinated attack from the bears
jesus
they're pretty clever
people punch him in the face from the
attack what there's a story of like a
someone an old woman working an old man
working at an el mory
apple
the nose is like the weak spot yeah so
if you just punch it then like like the
bear's just like oh what the [ __ ] is
this
kind of small but the brown bears you
did that they'd rip your [ __ ] arms
so they made like a death star weakness
on the the black bears
poke it and they're just [ __ ] pretty
much effective
just to get a pencil and they're [ __ ]
terrified
buried
[Laughter]
yeah that's scary what
is he laughing about bears be careful
this is why we
just which is just fantastic advice from
chrissy nice
just wondering yes be careful
next time i'll lure it into an acid
sulphuric bath
and see how the bear likes it apparently
there's a ghost wolf
near mount fuji that i want to go and
discover ghostly wolves in japan
yeah a few hundred years ago there we go
no they
all went extinct yeah wow apparently in
the district near mount fuji
amongst the tallest mountains in the
country 3000 meters some nights you
could hear like a howl
of a wolf and they call it the ghost
wolf and i want to go and find it in the
video
or just discover trash taste special and
i'll do the drain
you just want to use it you just want to
try it everything goes back to the drone
like [ __ ] crack a tower doesn't it
why is one of you getting eaten in the
drone shot i come with a drone
by a ghost a specialist
why is this a war for ghost wolf because
no one's seen it
the mountains because because all the
wolves all the wolves in japan have gone
extinct
you want us to go and film a ghost that
a wolf that no one has ever seen
i heard i've heard it what we're gonna
film there's nothing [ __ ] pointless
you're going to the [ __ ] mountains
with a baseball bat just redo some kind
of like ghost hunter
i feel it it's presence oh the ghost
wolf
chris just walk around be like oh [ __ ]
oh it's trees
it's good content you know it is not
[ __ ] good it is one's gonna watch the
best cases
horror videos are like we're gonna go to
someplace haunted and all they do is
just like [ __ ] scream and like
nut everywhere every ten seconds i
thought of a ghost best case you find a
wolf you get an instagram selfie worst
case
[ __ ] recognized as heroes of wars
heroes of wolves
heroes of wars the wolf heroes in the uk
no
foxes right yeah we have foxes which are
just like virgin wolves
[Music]
like scooby-doo i will go this way oh
that always works out yeah yeah yeah
let's just just split up the talkies
like guys i found it i don't know i saw
i saw some mountain people used to climb
up in japan some horror video about it
they just
a bunch of people climbed up this
mountain and just never came back they
made like an sos sign
in like the mountain and then they
rescued someone
on the mountain and they were like oh we
found you because you've s your sos sign
they're like what sos sign
oh god play scary music
obviously if we if ghosts exist we would
have some form of
one-tenth of some proof well we went in
a haunted tunnel and people say they
could hear a voice and there was like a
weird silhouette [ __ ] stupid of
course they [ __ ] want to hear they
hear what they want to hear
there's a silhouette of joey on the wall
in the tunnel yeah that was kind of
creepy that was creepy do we really
think right
yeah silhouette can be done by anything
though everything is explainable i think
people just want there to be something
more because
they take comfort in knowing that you
know something just easily explains why
they're dumb
if i don't know something i'm like i'm
just dumb i don't know what it is it's
definitely not a ghost
do you think this mystical flying [ __ ] i
would have no idea what it is why would
i know
it's difficult [ __ ] yeah some shadow or
ghost i don't know
did you see the whole are you tweeting
about this i swear the ufo stuff right
oh yeah all the nasty songs yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of
just like i think it's super [ __ ]
cool yeah there's something there we so
technologically advanced we can't get it
i love how i love how people
we just accepted that there's just ufos
now some nonsense like
they just took some nonsense the cia was
like yeah so by the way uh
ufos do exist don't panic but we just
don't know what it is
yeah that's literally a definition of a
ufo
why is nobody ufo stands for
unidentified flying
objects and they couldn't identify it
therefore
by definition it is literally a ufo for
like what 80 years we were like that's a
bunch of nonsense
just bunch of hearsay you know because
it would be like one p or something you
know we wouldn't have
we talked about ufos are you talking
about aliens because there's plenty of
ufos in the history of earth
that have those ufos that do like weird
[ __ ] i guess i don't know
that's most ufos we don't really have
anything that like
before that was confirmed to be like
actually like like ufx
how do you know though well we didn't
know until cia told us that now there is
a report it says that there's you know
there's these vehicles that move
yeah i think i think in that report nasa
was saying that like yeah we've known
about this for like the past 50 years
the thing is if you you know if you
if they have a secret yeah they kept it
a secret because they didn't work
because then it's just weird that like
suddenly like by the way when we all
called you
all made you look [ __ ] well it kind
of seemed like soft disclosure like very
great
i feel like it was just weird that
nobody spoke about it nobody was like oh
that's weird okay
i mean what's because we're so limited
on the information how are we supposed
to react to it because like it's it's
not the first time
you've probably seen some weird [ __ ]
footage but it's always kind of us
always look so fast i mean i mean i
guarantee the majority of it is fake
yeah 100 yeah i mean i i would think the
majority of it is fake as well but i'm
sure like
there are some that are on the same
level as that cia footage yeah
that just were real and no one can
explain them
hence hence the term ufo right yeah but
it's normally synonymous with aliens
though and stuff like that right so
that's what it would normally
tend to would be in the same kind of if
someone's like i'm into ufos you're like
stay the [ __ ] away
you know that
same thing with ghosts right yeah i'm
sure there's aliens out there
on some planet if we manage to survive
and do the weird [ __ ] that we're doing
on earth i'm sure
i believe in like aliens and stuff but i
don't believe in those like [ __ ]
ufos crash landed and on to earth and
they you know aliens came in contact
with the family do you believe in ghosts
yeah
why because i've had like paranormal
experiences myself
like what so one of the scariest ones i
had was in
in sydney there's this place uh in manly
called the quarantine
center and it was during world war one i
think
it was the place where like all the
soldiers used to stop by
from overseas to get quarantined in case
they had like right illnesses and stuff
like that
so a lot of people died at this place
naturally right um
and they have like these like nighttime
tours for this place that you can go and
like you can go to like the hospitals
and like
all it's very creepy stuff right uh so i
went with my sister once for her
birthday i think it was
and my sister has like this weird i
guess you'd call it
sixth sense if you will you know take
that take that how you will all right
take that how you watching this
quivering yeah
take that how you will but like she she
has like that whatever that is
um and there was this one moment where
she was inside we were inside the
hospital and i don't have anything like
that i don't
pretend to feel like oh i feel a ghost
prison or anything like that i just find
it fascinating
but then we went into this like
particular like i think it was like a
nursery
and my sister just stopped and just
immediately started breaking down crying
and i was like what's wrong it's just a
dark room like you've been through this
entire hospital and it's this room where
she just suddenly breaks down she's like
i can't
i can't move past this point and she
just couldn't explain it there was just
she just felt something in this one
particular room and then later we found
out
that was the place where they would
euthanize all the soldiers that
couldn't survive whatever illness it was
like that's where like all the soldiers
like
basically died and i was like okay look
like
you can believe in like sixth sense or
and all that kind of [ __ ] all you want
but you have to admit
that's pretty [ __ ] terrifying
especially when you're there in person
i mean you know because i'm like again i
don't really believe in any of that
that's just coincidence like i used to
work at a haunted castle and my
colleagues always said they saw ghosts
but i'd be like like someone up the
window like there's an occasionally
present but no it's a window
when we expect something to be there we
you know our mind is the biggest [ __ ]
joke
that's ever been played like we our mind
tricks us in so many ways like
of course like i'm sure there's moments
where it's like you know you just psych
yourself out right
and you just like you just think you've
seen something because you're already in
that mindset
but yeah you know there are some
instances where i'm like oh that's
actually kind of creepy like
i don't know if it's a ghost i don't
know if it's sixth sense but it's
something yeah i mean i i
think there is something there there's
too many there are too many things i
feel that can't be
can't be explained like the ufo for
example you don't go through an entire
hospital and then
immediately start breaking down
but she was fine throughout the entire
hospital except for this one room what
it might have been building up but
my car it's it's you know it's like when
people give like
people people don't the mind is a really
[ __ ] weird thing that we don't
understand
you know like people give witness
testimony at like trials and stuff and
they
they 100 swear they saw stuff that they
didn't see yeah right so it's like
i don't know i find that we like to be
able to easily explain everything even
when we have no explanations like we
don't have an explanation we're like oh
it's ghosts or some [ __ ] i'm like well
that's just another
way for you to cope because you want an
explanation you know but maybe you just
don't know maybe you don't have the
capacity to know
what that noise but i find i find it
fascinating that we don't
know right and that there is a mystery
behind them that no one has really
figured out is it just in your head or
is there something
we're pretty [ __ ] stupid people in
general
yeah humans are pretty stupid
humans are very flawed right yeah and i
think it's also very flawless [ __ ] off
chris
you're a t-shirt and shorts and i came
back
right and and for some reason we like to
think that we can think of every single
answer
to everything we most certainly can
[ __ ] not i mean for
how many [ __ ] years we were just
fighting with sticks and stones oh yeah
why aren't we twitter's verified i mean
what's the greatest [ __ ] history of
it all of those ghosts
that is like topper miles yeah no like
i'm i'm completely okay with people
like you know believing
apart i don't force it but sometimes
people explain [ __ ] to me that i'm like
this terrible [ __ ]
like i can tell like like you know there
are a lot of like these kinds of
mystical mythical things where it's like
that's kind of too i i feel like what's
really muddied the water is just
how you know some people have obviously
monetized this you see like
you see like these ghosts uh these
ghosts like reality tv shows and i'm
just like this is just
investigation how are you supposed to
take this seriously anymore
like i felt like i've heard genuinely
like
things that just can't be explained and
i've also experienced some of that
myself so like
it's it's kind of like you know i i
don't think
that i would blame anyone for not
believing in ghosts believing in ghosts
i just feel like
the entire perception around it has been
warped because
of how this how these things have been
presented and the reality tv shows
around it and these the people you kind
of see
believing in these kinds of things kinds
of things right but i feel like yeah
like i absolutely don't blame people for
like seeing those shows and being like
it's all [ __ ] like it's all it's all
it's entertaining whatever it's
entertainment whatever but like you know
i personally believe in it because it's
more fun and interesting i just think
that oh there might be something there
i mean i i don't know if i believe in
you ufos there's nothing to believe in
they are real
if you say aliens then that's a leap of
faith yeah you know you're starting to
make that
yeah guaranteed we're recording this
right now there's going to be someone
in the comment section that has a story
that just can't there will be there
always is there always is but then i
also also find that
you know i think that there's something
in your life that makes you more likely
to believe in them
like there's some something in your
personality or emotional something that
happened in your life that tends to make
you more likely to be
receptive to that stuff right i mean i
don't know why i'm so [ __ ]
pessimistic
you must be very funny
but i know when this comes up i just
don't say anything because i know that
this is one of those topics people who
believe in it you you just they're so
emotional about it and so invested yeah
i'm not i'm really not for people get
really offended when you're like
how dare you and it's like so i just
stopped i just i i never like if i meet
someone who's like i have this ghost
experience i'm like oh great
yeah i mean it's kind of like on the
same level as like religion right
because
obviously someone who believes in ghosts
had a very personal experience and
obviously that meant a lot to them and
it's like
obviously you know if they say their
experience it's kind of like it's kind
of a bit of a dick
to be like um actually i don't want to
invalidate how anyone felt
or experienced anything but but also on
the second time on the other hand you
know you want to be logical about things
and you want to try and
you know i think i think healthy
skepticism is good right like just just
you know
i i can't stand people parties are like
you're wrong you're religious [ __ ] go
home
like i can't like on the contrary though
i can't stand people who are like
explain everything as like supernatural
or ghosts or whatever it's so annoying
and i'm just like
no no no like i i get some situations
but like you know
you're you're getting divorced with your
wife was not because of the ghost
there's nothing supernatural
you know there's like people who like
chuck away everything is like
supernatural or like aliens
those people i'm just like all right
i saw it it's [ __ ] awful you know
what you know
about
[Music]
[Music]
it's like this one clip i don't know
what it's from but there's a clip and
it's titled uh
curb your sleeping with daughter or
something what
what the [ __ ] right so you have to click
on this all right
curb your sleep so that's not the
correct english
it's something like that right and it's
luther he walked he's in this room with
this man and the whole family is there
yeah and he's like so why did you sleep
with your daughter
and then he's like well you see i i was
just
on the floor and uh god compelled me to
have her like do that and i'm like
that he's like god asked you to do that
and he's like yes
god asked you to do this so the curb
your enthusiasm music starts playing
it's terrible it's like oh god that [ __ ]
like that is when you're like oh god
this whole uh this
spiritual religious stuff yeah that's
when it gets a little loony
yeah it's quite common though but it's
really easy to like brainwash if they're
your
family right you know because you raised
them and you know so yeah i mean but
that's like the extreme
i mean i feel like i feel like most
people were in there i was just throwing
it
out
cliff honestly just sleep with your
daughter
curb you and like curb your sleeping
with daughter that's just an amazing
title in and of itself this is a very
funny clip i thought i didn't do it
justice at all please go watch it
is this in your series i'll laugh i'll
pay you 150
yeah so i got 150 dollars from connor
all right
what did you say it was a yoda clip of a
guy
doing like a yoda joke with a yoda hand
puppet
it was actually okay it's really funny
thomas what's
what's a jedi called what was it what's
that what's a fat jedi use
a heavy shaver
150 i was so happy he spent 80 dollars
trying to get me to laugh and he [ __ ]
won i wanted to just take his money i
got a profit though
he gambled right a heavy shaver
the worse i feel like the internet i
feel like the internet just like [ __ ]
ruins my sense of humor because i don't
even know what i find funny anymore
normal jokes just i just can't laugh at
actually
i need like some funny sound screaming
and someone getting hurt or something
or all three times there's a lot of
subreddits of people
getting injured yeah i didn't realize
there's so many subreddits for like
people fighting
like just mobile phone videos people
fighting
world style right yeah people love that
[ __ ] i didn't realize people love it
i mean like that's kind of like
i mean i don't actively search for it
but whenever it pops out my twitter feed
i'm like
all right i got time i got it i have 30
seconds yeah
i like it when it's school kids fighting
i don't know why because it's so
wholesome because it's like a slapping
contest like slap each other and then i
was like
in the background it's like i think
there's just something primal about it
right that's why there's so many fights
i think that's just like there's there's
a reason why like there are so many
[ __ ]
fights in clubs right because like
uncivilized
there's a reason why there are so many
[ __ ] fights in clubs right because
you know you put a bunch of guys they
get drunk and they like learn
like they live on their primal instincts
so what they're gonna do they're either
gonna get horny
or want to start a fight which is the
two [ __ ] things that happens in clubs
so if they can't get with a girl
most of the time a fighter that's our
hands yeah yeah exactly you know
fair enough can't be helped logic
logically
just walks into the club just starts
punching everyone
i remember when i was like 18 i got a
fight with the bouncer because i lost 10
pounds
so it was a low point a low point i like
how did you explain how did you lose the
ten pounds
so i i i yeah i went around this
clubbing so i've lost i was really drunk
and he was like you gotta get out and
then he like like grabbed me and threw
me out
like a like a toy yeah and they got back
to my apartment
she cried stripped off the ten pounds
just fell out
started a war with an entire nightclub
over 10 pounds i mean
as an 18 year old with no money that was
like all my lifestyles
yeah that's a lot you guys ever been
thrown out of clubs
luckily not i guess that time i was
fortnight dancing but that's about it oh
yeah that's about it right i think i've
been thrown out one club
were you too drunk huh were you too
drunk yeah so this is of course this was
in university
right and uh i think i think this is
like right like not fresh this week but
like week two of freshers week
and of course you have you have the pre
lash right you get you get drunk
and you know back when you're [ __ ] 18
you don't [ __ ] know your limits yeah
you just you just drink as much as you
want right lose a ten i start
questioning everyone yeah yeah
exactly exactly
and also as a uni student you try to get
drunk as efficiently as you can because
you don't have the [ __ ] money for
traffic jobs right
so i mean it was still a student night
but i didn't want to spend money to get
drinks so
had like [ __ ] four five six beers
before going to the club and you know as
a student you i always had like a bottle
of like well like a half bottle of cheap
vodka you know just just
like yourself as you do as yourself up
with
a bottle just to keep yourself drunk
right because there's no
there's no more efficiency with a tank
full yeah there's no more efficient way
to get drunk as a student
pound shots or something you know just
ask for like one shot it wasn't one
pound shots in [ __ ] bristol man i'll
tell you that
of course this isn't [ __ ] swansea man
everything is one yeah but like uh so
you i had this uh half bottle of vodka
cheap vodka probably like check off
vodka it wasn't smelling off
music of course of course
basically plastic sanitizer and uh so we
get we get to the club and we realize
that people are checking
are the bouncers are checking pockets
for anyone like in my situation who's
trying to sneak in
some bottle of vodka and i was like well
[ __ ] um i have to dispose of this
somehow
uh and by this point by the time i've
gotten to
this club it was already half drunk so
it was like
about a quarter litre vodka left um and
my mate goes just hide it around the
corner next to the dumpster in case you
want it and i'm like i gotta i got a
better idea i'm gonna do a pro gamer
move
and i [ __ ] down the thing
so i [ __ ] downed this thing right uh
and i was like
i can't feel it i'm a [ __ ] pro five
minutes you'll be fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly so
get in the club completely fine not even
drunk go go to the bar get my first
drink i'm like
having a [ __ ] amazing time and so i'm
in the middle of the dance floor
and like it just it just like there
wasn't a transition
right i you you know how sometimes you
have like a cool transition where it's
just like you can
you go you go from merry to drunk to
absolute pissed
i went from like tier one to tier ten in
like
the matter of a second it's like boom
i was listening on the dance floor and
then i was like [ __ ] everything's
spinning
everything's spinning and i'm sorry
and so i'd never been this drunk in my
life probably and i was this drunk
for the first time in my life in a club
and i'm just like i'm i
am a smart boy i am an electronic
engineer i am not going to let anyone
know
that i'm [ __ ] drunk
so without talking to my friends i
[ __ ] go to the nearest table
i could and uh it was like right
opposite the bar
and like i was the room was like [ __ ]
spinning around me
it took every ounce of energy to not
like topple over
but i somehow managed to get to this
table and not topple over and i'm just
like
i'm going to wait this out i thought i
could wait this out right so
um there was a bottle of water we'll fix
it yeah yeah yeah so so
um i see on this table and there's just
this glass of water there right
and because the room is [ __ ] spinning
around me i just [ __ ] stare at this
water
i i like you like this is me using a
hundred percent of my brain this is like
this is like the mind expands moment
like i i can game the system nobody
nobody's gonna ever know i'm [ __ ]
drunk so i'm [ __ ] staring at this
water [ __ ] intently just trying to
keep my focus on something
so the room just stopped spinning around
me and i could just and i could just
like
focus on something yeah and then five
minute passes
and so i i i feel the top of my shoulder
and it's the [ __ ] bouncer
and he's like mate you gotta [ __ ] go
out and i was like why what what have i
done i've just been sitting here and
he's like you've been sitting there for
an hour and a half staring at that glass
of water holy [ __ ]
so what felt like five minutes i uh i
had been just like
sitting like [ __ ] eyes open staring
at this glass of water for an
hour and a half just doing this sounds
almost like time travel
yeah yeah you did yeah
you know i totally forgot existed but i
used to like take a canteen in
well there's a little like like an old
general yeah like the little like
twister
big brain they can't find it if you like
i just like attach it to my hair like
pants
like inside your pants yeah you put it
in my pants pretty so that's how
people had guns put in my pants and then
whenever you like order a vodka you just
like
top it up put it in yeah you're a
student
and this looks like three pounds and i
was like oh my god this is robbery
yeah because you know if i spent more
than like ten dollars a night i'd be
like i'm broke yeah of course so i had
to find ways so i would just fill up a
canteen full of vodka and then i asked
my friends they want some too you know
just
everyone loved me they were like what a
role model connor can make my double
vodka into a quadruple vodka
fantastic with his personal style that's
a life hack 20 uh students out there
after the world stops
ending yeah don't do it now it's just
depressing if you do it now
yeah counting in your pants yeah do it
i'm sorry i had a canteen in my face
that was like the life hack yeah yeah no
one else i knew did it everyone thought
was a weirdo for buying a canteen what
kind of thought he was like i've
just just been doing it no one's done
this
have you ever done that where you've
figured out something on your own and
you found out that like everyone's been
doing it on the internet and you feel
like a
[ __ ] loser you figure out something
you're like i'm so [ __ ] smart yeah
and you find everyone else who's done it
he's like that christian i'm the only
one
it's my original idea every time by what
[ __ ] right
now fuji no one's ever done
how many [ __ ] times have we gone on
this episode now this has been tangent
in the episode
there's more tangent than episode
honestly
go and watch the newest episode and
final episode of uh
journey across japan yeah which should
be out around this time
and go listen to too much volcano on
itunes
oh
next year i think you've like pronounced
the
award who's gonna win who's gonna once
who's gonna win most english me or chris
best best guest second year running most
trip
the most
thanks for watching oh my god hey thanks
to the patrons as well who support the
show who's your favorite patron
barry i hope there's a
it is now there's it's barry roberts
what ryan roberts
[ __ ] off what is that my top page
oh okay don't come back all right
i missed the first half of this episode
when we were sober
yeah when we had topics and stuff we
spoke about
why is it always the chris episode where
the endings are just like
drunk remember when we treat you with a
spur remember
you with respect
yeah cheers and the glasses are empty
show you just how well it goes
cheers cheers guys hey if you like to
support the show then make sure to go to
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
uh send us your memes on the subreddit
and if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify also go check out chris i mean
you know he is you know who he is at
this point he's basically the fourth
member
chris ballrand offer browning
he's not an official member until he
gets twitter verified yeah i'm gonna say
that
once he's twitter verified then we'll
think about it if jackdaws is watching
this let's make it happen mate
that's it i know you're busy but this is
kind of important
you're right
i'm tired of chris's nonsense all right
i guess we'll see you in like three
months whenever the [ __ ] you come back
hey hope you enjoyed and we'll see you
guys next episode bye bye
pounding the rock
[Music]
you